Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
So wie sind denn die goldenen Zwanziger bisher für dich gelaufen.
Hör mir auf mit den goldenen Zwanzigern, du hast damit angefangen, du hast das beschrieben, guck dir das an.
Logbuchnetzpolitik. Nummer dreihundertsechsundfünfzig haben wir, genau und es ist der neunzehnte August und wir waren ein wenig im Urlaub.
Du warst im Urlaub, ich nicht. Ich habe hier Folgen gemacht, mein Freund. Ja, immerhin.
Wie A2. Ja, immerhin. Ja, immerhin. Das war auch gut, aber na ja, so ein bisschen Sommer hast du ja auch genossen, oder?
Goldenen goldenen Zwanni. Kriegst du hier gleich der goldene Zwanni.
Ja, das Jahr macht's einem etwas schwierig, das alles so zu genießen, wie man das normalerweise so erwartet hätte. Keine Frage, aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Ja
Können wir nicht viel dran ändern. Wir geben zu, wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen außer Spur, vielleicht mal gleich äh voranzustellen.
Tim kommt jetzt König zurück. Wir sind aus der Spur, wir waren im Urlaub. Ja du.
Ach du bist nicht aus der Spur oder was?
Ich bin.
Okay, das ist gut. Ähm ich muss mich also wieder in die ganze äh Thematik reingewöhnen und mich selber auch so ein bisschen an den Gedanken dran,
wieder in so einen Podcast Rhythmus reinzukommen, weil ich habe bis.
Bis zur Sommerpause schon drei Viertel der Sendungsmängel gemacht, die ich im letzten Jahr gemacht habe, also es ist einfach, es war einfach ein bisschen viel.
Ja was willst du sonst machen?
Ja, man konnte ja auch nix anderes machen. Was bleibt einem außer Podcast noch übrig in dieser Welt?
Wobei Corona ist ja durch. Also wenn ich mir wenn ich mir draußen angucke, was auf der Straße los ist, ne, Corona ist vorbei.
Mir hat den Eindruck gewinnt man, deswegen ist es ja jetzt auch nicht mehr vorbei,
das ging dann doch äh ganz schnell. Ja, gut, wir wollen jetzt nicht so viel über Corona zahlen, äh sinnieren uns äh dann doch vielleicht eher mal wieder den netzpolitischen Geschehen zuwenden. Da ist ja auch noch ein bisschen was passiert.
Ja, wir haben jetzt einen Monat nicht berichtet, insofern machen wir jetzt einen kleinen Abriss dessen, was wir im letzten Monat äh passiert ist.
Genau, was wir so so sekundär wahrgenommen haben, was vorgefeilt ist, sobald es uns in dem Moment interessiert hat. Aber es hilft auch enorm mal abzuschalten. Das.
Macht man sich selber immer nicht so richtig klar, also ich zumindest und wenn man's dann doch mal macht, dann ist es irgendwie auch schön.
Aber jetzt versuchen wir langsam mal wieder. Also ich versuche jetzt langsam wieder reinzukommen. Du bist natürlich voll ordnernd total am Start und.
Ich rege mich hier jeden Tag über die Nachrichten auf, ja.
Och. Ja, da fange ich jetzt langsam erst wieder mit an.
Ich lasse mir da ich lasse mir doch von solchen Weltkatastrophen meinen Optimismus nicht verderben.
Ja äh Trump will uns TikTok wegnehmen.
Oh Gott, mein TikTok. Damit habe ich mich den ganzen Sommer beschäftigt.
Das ist so eine ähm.
Eine Debatte. Wir haben ja also was zu dem sozialen Netzwerk TikTok zu sagen ist, dazu hatten wir ja hier mal ein LMP Spezial ähm oder weißt du, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's spezial war, einfach.
Nö, war kein Spezial. Aber wir haben uns den mal ein wenig gewidmet, was da so abgeht, was da so zensurtechnisch äh läuft et cetera.
Und was ich nicht müde werden kann, zu betonen ist ja diese sozialen Netzwerke definieren.
Gesellschaften und deren Leitbilder, ne, der diese sozialen Netzwerke sind,
ein größerer Teil dessen, wie Menschen miteinander interagieren und die formen wahnsinnig,
stark
das, was, was die Gesellschaft irgendwie lebt, fühlt, denkt und tut. Und äh das hat natürlich Effekte dadurch, dass was durch die verkürzten Darstellungen, die dort stattfinden, ähm ich weiß gar nicht genau, ob das nur ein
Mehm ist oder inzwischen auch schon wissenschaftlich erhärtet, aber,
Es ist irgendwie seit vielen Jahrzehnten wohl erstmalig der Fall, dass nicht der größere Teil der Kinder antwortet, dass sie Astronauten werden möchten.
Sondern die wollen Instagramerin werden und Influencer oder Youtuberin und so so ähm vielversprechende.
Gesellschaftliche Beiträge leisten und ähm das heißt das, was,
dieser gesamte Bereich der sozialen Medien ist, ist inzwischen einfach Macht. Ja, das behandeln wir ja hier in der Sendung oft genug, sei es wenn es darum geht, äh,
eine Werbung zu machen, politische Werthaltung zu schalten, die Aufmerksamkeit von Menschen irgendwo hinzulenken und von irgendetwas anderem abzulenken. Wir haben so schöne Phänomene wie das,
wirklich jetzt wenig qualifizierte Personen in relativ wichtige politische Positionen kommen.
Und diese sozialen Netzwerke haben da immer irgendwie ein bisschen was mit zu tun. Und deswegen ist es natürlich für eine.
Weltmacht,
die der ist gelungen ist, dafür zu sorgen, dass sie auch die zentralen und wichtigen sozialen Netzwerke dieser Welt kontrolliert. Etwas ärgerlich,
Wenn eine andere Welt macht, auf einmal auch ein erfolgreiches soziales Netzwerk hat und in diesem Falle eben TikTok.
Und jetzt entscheidet sich Donald Trump in dem in seinem gesegneten Entscheidungswahn.
Dass er der TikTok nicht mehr haben will. Und äh führt an, was also pass auf. Ich meine, weil TikTok.
Ähm Daten von Menschen überall aus der Welt und damit auch von US-Bürgern sammelt und deswegen eine,
Sicherheitssorge ist, weil ja die Datenanfragen des chinesischen, der chinesischen Regierung hier anfragen könnten. Also kurz übersetzt, das Ding.
Gehört im Prinzip den Chinesen und im Zweifelsfall hängen da deren Geheimdienste drin. Sagt der Präsident der USA,
Der Präsident der USA fürchtet sich,
dass das chinesische soziale Netzwerk von den chinesischen Geheimdiensten potentiell infiltriert sein könnte. Ich würde sagen, das ist gar nicht so eine schlechte Vermutung, ja.
Allerdings,
Sagt das der Präsident des einen Landes. Wurde klar ist, dass es die Geheimdienste machen, während es in China immer noch nur eine Vermutung ist. Diese Vermutung ist im Zweifelsfall richtig, aber die Belege haben wir nun mal von den USA.
So richtig stört ihn nur, dass die Russen da nichts zu sagen haben.
Und er entscheidet sich jetzt und hier,
Wir also hier sieht man, was da alles mit reinkommt. Entscheidet sich jetzt mehr oder weniger als Executive Order.
Der den Unternehmens, die TikTok betreiben und dem Unternehmen WeChat,
pretty much einfach den Geschäftsbetrieb in den USA zu untersagen oder so stark zu erschweren, dass er einfach nicht mehr möglich ist. Ja, indem,
der anderen Unternehmen untersagt wird, mit denen Geschäfte zu machen,
Also er sagt, de facto euer Geschäftsbetrieb wird in den USA Kraft meiner Entscheidung zum Erliegen kommen.
Es sei denn, ihr verkauft früh genug an jemandem, dem ich vertraue und die ersten, die sich melden, sind irgendwie so Microsoft und ORR. Ja? Und.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man da jetzt lachen, drüber lachen soll oder drüber weinen soll, weil als deutsche Bürgerin stehen wir auf jeden Fall an der Seitenlinie.
Und haben die Wahl, ob wir vom Regen und der Umgehung der Scheiße direkt in die Traufe wollen, ja, aber ähm ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt hier für.
Für Europäerinnen und Europäer irgendeinen Vorteil hat, wenn sich jetzt hier zwei.
Potentielle Weltmächte, um die Nutzerinnendaten zanken. Und ich habe das ja hier schon mal gesagt, ähm
Der Kapitalismus fickt immer in beide Richtungen und das kann man hier jetzt genau sehen, weil sobald da mal
In diesem schönen Internet, wo immer alles frei und freier Markt und ey, kein ne, hier darf jeder machen, was er will und äh keine Sperren und so weiter. Sobald da mal irgendetwas gegen die,
größeren geostrategischen Interessen der USA läuft.
Oder da auf einmal eine Konkurrenz entsteht, ne, indem in dem Land, das immer sagt, der freie Markt und und die freie Konkurrenz ist gut für die Bürger. Ähm
sobald da mal irgendwie eine nennenswerte Konkurrenz entsteht, geht das natürlich hier ganz schnell rund. Und das ist,
Letztendlich hält er dir den die Knarre an den Kopf und sagt äh bitte einmal unterschreiben. Das ist einfach nur ein Angebot,
dass äh Bitance letztendlich nicht ablehnen kann, weil das heißt entweder euer Geschäft wird von mir zerstört werden oder ihr kauft es, ihr verkauft es jetzt und,
Allein, dass es danach zerstört wird, hat Würde, hat natürlich durchaus seinen Einfluss auf den Verkaufspreis, ne?
Ja, also ich meine, diese ganze Executive Order, die er da ähm erlassen äh hat, ist halt total
wirre wie immer, also äh einerseits ist es überhaupt nicht klar, ob das in irgendeiner Form eine rechtliche Basis äh hat, die sich irgendwie aufrechterhalten lässt, weil das sind ja auch alles irgendwie beliebige
Apps quasi, die er sich jetzt herausgesucht hat. Und wie das eben so ist mit,
und so weiter, das sollte ja normalerweise dann auch Uniform äh anwendbar sein, von daher ist so ein bisschen unklar, die Implikationen sind natürlich weitreichend, also,
so ein bisschen auf TikTok konzentriert finde ich in gewisser Hinsicht eigentlich noch viel interessanter, dass er dagegen vorgeht, weil während TikTok einfach nur ein,
populäres, dominantes, kulturell erfolgreiches äh Sozial Network ist, ist TikTok ja zumindest derzeit noch nicht sehr viel mehr als das.
Wiederum ist.
Ist ein Ökosystem und vor allem, was man ja nicht vergessen darf, äh auch ein Payment-System in China. Und so wie diese Exective äh Bedeutung, so wie diese Executive,
Order angelegt ist, wird es ja quasi amerikanischen Unternehmen verboten werden,
in irgendeiner Form mit diesen Entitäten Geschäfte zu treiben, was im Zweifelsfall eben auch bedeuten könnte, dass zum Beispiel amerikanische Smartphones.
In China diese App nicht mehr tragen dürften.
Und das äh ist wahrscheinlich nicht das worauf es hinauslaufen,
wird, ne, also da, da wüsste der Trump wahrscheinlich schon, dass er da mit Apple signifikant schadet, aber das ist das, das ist der Bereich, in dem er, in dem er sich da bewegt, ne, also er,
Ich denke, sein Plan ist, also er kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, es gibt kein TikTok mehr in den USA, aber er kann halt dafür sorgen, dass den der Geschäftsbetrieb,
in den USA einfach so unangenehm wird und so feindselig einfach für sie ist, weil sie
alle möglichen Auflagen haben und Unternehmen, die mit ihnen Geschäfte treiben, sich rechtfertigen müssen oder zum Beispiel Unternehmen, die mit ihnen Geschäfte treiben, auf einmal, was weiß ich, für die Zusammenarbeit mit der Regierung nicht mehr und so weiter und so fort, ne.
Dass dass das natürlich schon also die kurze Antwort ist nein, die lange Antwort ist, na klar kann der denen das Leben zur Hölle machen.
Ja, es soll einfach Unruhe stiften. So, letzten Endes, was, äh, worum es halt immer geht bei Trump, einfach Unsicherheit in den Raum werfen und vor allem, alle zerfetzen sich darüber das Maul, damit eben nicht über,
weiß ich, das neue Buch von Michael Cohn, äh gesprochen wird mit Golden Schauers und äh,
vor allem nicht über seine Attacke auf das Wahl äh System in USA, ja, was einfach auch so mega krass ist. Ja und das sind halt einfach diese ganzen Nebelkerzen. Sogar wir reden jetzt darüber.
Man muss natürlich schon ein bisschen noch die Meterperspektive nehmen, also Indien,
Seit jeher mit China Entspannungen hat TikTok auch verbannt.
Man ist natürlich in Indien die Situation sich immer vor Augen führen das sind glaub ungefähr eins Komma drei Millionen Milliarden Menschen. Ähm der größere Teil von denen ist noch nicht digitalisiert.
Und äh die bauen da jetzt quasi die haben da wird eine ganze Menge entstehen an Wachstum, an äh Prosperity und so weiter und die überlegen sich natürlich auch, ob sie jetzt äh,
quasi das Internet in die Breite der Bevölkerung tragen, nur damit das Business am Ende von Facebook, Google.
Und Bike-Dance gemacht wird und Netflix oder ob sie sagen, Moment mal,
vielleicht digitalisieren wir unser Land auch auf eine Weise, dass wir etwas davon haben. Ne? Ähm.
Das sind finde ich, je nachdem wie man darauf blickt, noch nicht mal so falsche Ideen, ja, sich sich zu überlegen, naja, wenn wir hier.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die wie zum heutigen Tage der politisch korrekte Begriff ist, aber sagen wir mal, ein Land, was noch sehr viel ökonomische Entwicklung äh,
Entwicklungspotential ausnutzen kann, ähm ob wir uns da direkt äh geschlagen geben oder ob wir eben äh protektionistisch unseren Markt,
uns uns sichern, ja? Kann ich durchaus verstehen diese Perspektive zu verfolgen.
Ist ja auch in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keine neue Perspektive, wenn man jetzt sich mal die Standardwirtschaft anschaut,
kannst du halt über Zölle und Handelsverträge im Prinzip alles regulieren und deine eigene Wirtschaft äh entsprechend schützen und zusehen, dass bestimmte Branchen äh noch ein Entwicklungspotential haben und eben nicht durch irgendwelche
Importe,
an der Stelle geschwächt werden, wo es dir einfach nicht passt, Klassiker, Landwirtschaft, auch in USA in Europa natürlich ganz, ganz stark, gibt viele Beispiele,
und das Internet,
Na ja, sieht so was eben nicht vor. Also du kannst halt schwer äh einen Import über das Internet verhindern, weil das Internet ist halt überall und das ist schon etwas,
wo wahrscheinlich mehrere Sachen zusammenkommen. Ich meine, bei Trampel sind's jetzt wahrscheinlich letztlich weniger protektionistische Züge äh rein in wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht. Das ist eben wahrscheinlich am Ende einfach auch alles viel zu komplex
da ist es dann vielleicht dann doch eher ähm einfach das das Big Picture eben.
Diskussionen äh verlagert, diesen diesen China äh Krieg da der letztlich ja auch nur rassistisch geprägt ist,
voranzutreiben et cetera, aber indisches Beispiel ist ganz gut, ne? Weil wie du sagst,
Indien sieht sich eigentlich schon als Player, also sie wissen halt auf jeden Fall, dass sie ein großer Markt sind, aber sie wollen eben vielleicht verhindern,
Das dominante Player, wo er jetzt auch absehbar ist, dass die sich quasi ihrer Existenz einfach
so als Platzhirsch breit machen, dass du dann eben irgendwann nicht mehr dran vorbeikommst. Sehen wir ja hier. Ich meine,
Was geht hier irgendwie nennenswert gegen Facebook an, ja? Jeder Club hat hier irgendwie seine.
Äh äh Seite und in dem Moment, wo die dann eben ihre Businessaktivitäten ähm weiter ausbreiten und anfangen, selber zu verkaufen, selber Geld auszugeben. Das haben sie ja oft durchaus vor.
Auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen. Ja, dann wird's natürlich in zunehmendem Maße schwierig, in irgendeiner Form mit der eigenen,
Wirtschaft, mit der eigenen Digitalwirtschaft noch dagegen zu halten. Sehen wir ja eigentlich in Deutschland auch ganz gut. Ich meine, was.
Was hat Deutschland sozusagen doch zu sagen im Internet, ja? Also da gibt.
Ey, wir haben jede Kommentarspalte der Welt können wir reinschreiben. Das ist so ungefähr.
Das ist so ungefähr ja.
Ähm ich die Methoden sind natürlich Wahnsinn, ne. Also wenn man ich meine, der äh CEO von,
Microsoft kann sich natürlich freuen, ne. Also ich mal ernsthaft, stell dir mal vor, du bist in der Situation zu überlegen so, oh, da habe ich ja so ein.
So ein echt gutlaufendes Geschäft, was uns irgendwie
zu teuer geworden ist, äh zu ist uns irgendwie davongelaufen, das müssen wir mal kaufen und in die Tasche stecken, bevor das nachher von von der Konkurrenz betrieben wird. Und dann geht der Präsident deines, deines Staates dahin und hätte die Knarre an den Kopf und sagt
Entweder ihr verkauft dem das jetzt oder ich mache das kaputt, ne. Das ist ja, also.
Nicht nur die Knarre an Kopf in der einen Hand in der anderen die andere Hand ist halt ausgestreckt mit und wir wollen dann auch sozusagen Tanz jedem haben, ne? Weil wir haben euch ja den Job sozusagen vermittelt, ne. Das hat er ja so gesagt. Das ist ja einfach unfassbar.
Wahnsinn. Das ist absoluter Irrsinn.
Ja, der absolute Irrsinn.
Oh Mann.
Begleitet uns.
Und dann, jetzt wird von der, vor der Balkanisierung des Internets äh gewarnt und ich bin.
Also ja, die Bäckernisierung des Internets ist ein riesiges, wäre ein riesiges Problem. Ich bin andererseits,
vorsichtig an, bei dieser Art von Wirtschaftskriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen diesen Begriff ins Feld zu führen.
Weil was da also mein mein Eindruck ist, dass hier etwas,
Machtkämpfe stattfinden. Und es geht am Ende niemandem darum, das Internet zu balkanisieren, sondern es geht den Leuten darum, das Internet zu kontrollieren.
Und ähm gerade die Idee der äh USA auf diesem Wege ist ja genau die gewesen, ne? Lasst dieses freie Netz nehmen.
Das kann uns die Welt zu Kundin machen, ja? Und äh das äh hat hat gut funktioniert. Insofern.
Kann ich, ich kann mir genauso gut vorstellen, wenn demnächst irgendwann mal irgendein Land auf die Idee kommt, mal einen Microsoft Dienst auszuschließen, wie laut der Trump dann sich aber um die Balkanisierung des Internets fürchtet, ne.
Ja, das ist das sind unschöne Auseinandersetzungen und da sieht man,
wenn wenn solche Auseinandersetzungen geführt werden, dann werden dann sehe ich, kann man im Prinzip immer sagen.
Es ist ein Regen aus Tränen der Idealisten, die dieses Internet mal gebaut haben, weil alle irgendwie dachten, dass wenn man eine freie Spielwiese für alle macht
dass da,
aus welchem wahnsinnigen Grund auch immer, nicht multinationale Milliardenkonzerne entstehen, die einfach allen diktieren, wie die, wie der Hase läuft. Irgendjemand hat gedacht, da würde nicht passieren,
ja? Ähm,
oder hatte zumindest, hat gehofft, es würde nicht passieren und uns hat's dann an den Methoden gemangelt, äh das zu verhindern. Aber jetzt letztendlich zanken sich da halt zwei der Bullis äh im Sandkasten.
Und äh wir sitzen daneben und können, hoffen, dass wir nicht so viel Sand abkriegen. Das ist irgendwie unsere Rolle. Schön.
Goldenen Zwanziger Tim, Spitze. Danke, ne. So.
Super, ne? Ja, keine Ursache. Dachte mal was anderes, weißt du? Hör mal, derselbe Trott.
Die Corona-Warn-App ist jetzt, warte mal, warte mal, fünf, du müsste jetzt drei, ist jetzt drei Monate, ne? Ich glaube, am fünfzehnten Juni ist die released worden. Ist ja erst zwei Monate.
Nicky jetzt erstmal stumm und äh.
Am fünfzehnten Mai release? Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr.
Ähm es ist.
Auf jeden Fall ist sie.
Sechzehnten Juni ist er erschienen.
So, wir haben jetzt also zwei Monate und drei Tage und ähm.
Noch nicht so lang ist.
Ähm aber äh man hat uns damals versprochen.
Dass man innerhalb eines Monats alle Labore daran anschließen würde. Nochmal die Erinnerung, die Idee der App ist es.
Die gesamten Meldewaren und Testketten zu beschleunigen, ja, Situation, du hast ein positives Testergebnis, musst nun deine Kontakte.
Alarmieren, äh um sie von ihrem Infektionsrisiko in Kenntnis zu setzen, damit sie möglichst wiederum ihre Kontakte reduzieren und sich potenziell vielleicht testen lassen. Ja, und um somit das Infektionsgeschehen,
zu äh begrenzen. Das möchte die App auf zwei Wegen tun. Erstens die Mail, die die die Mitteilung des Testergebnisses an dich soll schneller passieren und zweitens die,
Warnung von Kontakten, die du hattest, soll beschleunigt werden, potentiell eben auch vielleicht Leute erreichen, von denen du jetzt nicht.
Genau weißt, dass du sie ähm einem Risiko ausgesetzt hast, zum Beispiel, weil er drei Stunden neben denen im ECE gesessen hast und,
dich nicht getraut hast nach einer Nummer zu fragen, ne. Das kann ja passiert ja. So und ähm.
Das ist ja auch eine plumpe Anmache irgendwie.
Weil ich glaube die ist gar nicht so schlecht. Ich.
Nicht so schlecht. Du siehst so viral aus. Willst du mir deine Nummer geben?
Du kannst einfach, du, ich warte auf mein Testergebnis und ich habe mir gedacht, ich würde es dir ganz gerne mitteilen.
Ach echt, du hast auch einen Coronatest gemacht. Das ist ja interessant.
Okay, ähm also das sind die beiden Ideen dieser App und ähm.
Das soll spezifisch dadurch beschleunigt werden, dass du im Prinzip du du machst deinen Test, ne? Lässt dir da dein, deinen Q-Tip in den Hals stecken und dann.
War die Idee auf dem Proben Begleitschein ist dann ein QR-Code, den scannst du in deiner App ein und äh der sagt letztendlich, ne, ist das eine eine Nummer für diesen Test und die App fragt dann regelmäßig an einer API,
ist hier äh Jackpot oder nicht und wenn ein positives Ergebnis dort bekannt wird, dann kann die App dir das mitteilen.
Und das verkürzt den Weg, der Sonne stattfindet und jetzt muss ich tatsächlich sagen, ich habe da ja,
vor einigen Wochen mich auch im TV mal zu geäußert und dann wurde zum Beispiel ich auch auf Twitter darauf hingewiesen, dass es nicht stimmen würde, dass diese Mitteilung per Fax,
Brief oder Telefon oder gar nicht stattfinden würden. Wir hatten jetzt äh auf Twitter eine,
repräsentative Stichprobe. Nein, wir haben auf Twitter mal umgehört und es häufen sich zumindest tatsächlich die Beschwerden von Leuten, die sagen, dass sie zum Beispiel auch Testergebnisse gar nicht mitgeteilt bekommen haben
ne? Wir haben diesen Bayerns Skandal da, ich meine, ganz Bayern ist ein Skandal, um mal den Strahl langsam von Baden-Württemberg zu lösen.
Jetzt legst du dich mit Bayern an. Super.
Münchener aufgepasst.
Stuttgart ist erster. Ihr habt erst mal Ruhe jetzt und nein und ähm.
Wir haben tatsächlich, es häufen sich die Einzelfälle, in denen Menschen berichten, Testergebnisse stark verspätet oder ähm,
Gar nicht äh mitgeteilt bekommen zu haben. Und die Idee wäre eben, durch dieses QR-Code System gewesen, ruppi zuppi. Ja,
Dafür musste aber, das war ja auch die Herausforderung, die heterogene Laborlandschaft Deutschlands.
Daran angebunden werden und das äh war zum Zeitpunkt des Launches noch nicht der Fall. Und äh zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sind ungefähr drei Viertel der Labore.
Also sparen meinte hundertfünfzehn von einhunderteinundfünfzig. Ich habe aber auch.
Berichte gelesen von wo von einer größeren Anzahl von Laboren äh,
die Rede war, wie viele dieser Labore eigentlich zum selben Konglomrat gehören und letztlich vielleicht äh dieselbe Software benutzen, das kann ich jetzt an der Stelle nicht sagen
aber offenbar war die Einschätzung darüber, wie denn die Realität der Digitalisierung bei diesen Laboren aussieht. Ähm anders als es,
angenommen wurde.
Und jetzt gibt es hier eine vom Handelsblatt einen Bericht, ähm wo.
Ach so, ganz kurz, wenn diese QR-Codes Sache nicht funktioniert, dann hast du eben diesen
Tele-TAN, Vollbeck, ne, dann äh dann also erstens kriegst du,
langsamer dein Testergebnis mitgeteilt, ja? Irgendwie, also vielleicht sogar auch schneller, ne? Je nachdem wie gut dein Labor drauf ist und wie gut deine Ärztin drauf ist.
Ähm aber dann musst du die Meldung dann auch über diesen Teletan Weg gehen, also bei der, bei der Hotline anrufen, die davon überzeugen, dass du tatsächlich einen positiven Test hast und so weiter.
Ja gut, von der Ärztin sollte es ja normalerweise nicht abhängen. Der Idealfall ist natürlich
der Test liegt selbstverständlich in einem Labor ohnehin digital äh vor. Dann liegt auch irgendwann das Ergebnis davon natürlich vor und in dem Moment, wo dieses Ergebnis dort eingetragen wird
sollte deine idealen Welt natürlich diese Information mehr oder weniger umgehend an diese äh anderen Server durchgereicht werden, die die Telekom dort aufgesetzt hat und damit äh innerhalb von Sekunden auch bei der App landen können, nennen.
Ist eben nicht der Fall bisher bei den meisten, weil diese Anbindungen, diese Trivialanbindungen letztendlich ein paar Code für den verfluchten Test und,
was weiß ich, ne? Ja, nein, vielleicht. Zu übermitteln.
Ist es vor allem wirklich trivial. Also mir selbst wenn ich länger darüber nachdenke, mir fällt mir einfach da nichts ein, was wirklich irgendwie nennenswert komplex sein könnte.
Nee, denke ich auch. Allerdings ähm keine Sorge, äh T-Systems kümmert sich drum,
äh natürlich äh das habe ich ja auch hier schon öfter gesagt, wenn Tessist etwas macht, dann kriegen die den Auftrag deshalb, weil die groß genug sind, dass man weiß
die lassen die GmbH nicht platzen, wenn sie's verkacken und dann schnappen die sich eine kleine GmbH, die das umsetzt. In dem Fall die BS Software Development, ja? Und.
Jetzt äh ging es hier um eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen der KV Digital. Das ist eine Tochter der äh Kassenärztlichen Bundesvereinigung.
Und die KVD Gitarre hat sich schon darum gekümmert, als die Diskussion noch über eine zentralistische Lösung war. Also die waren schon durchaus interessiert daran, diesen Prozess zu beschleunigen. Ähm dann hat sich also die Telekom.
Beziehungsweise mit denen in ähm Verbindung gesetzt und jetzt meldet der die ähm,
KV digital. Ja, also die meisten Labore werden eben sehr unzufrieden mit der Umsetzung der Telekom.
Weil die Systeme, die sie da anbieten, nur auf Windows-Systemen,
laufen, das was die KV Digital eigentlich bauen wollte, hätte systemunabhängig funktioniert und die kriegen ihre beiden Standards Übermittlung von paar Bites irgendwie nicht äh in eine Ebene. Die Telekom sagt,
und das ist das ist so deutsch, das ist so geil. Also Telekom sagt auf Anfrage, die Entwicklung eines für beide geeigneten Vertragswerkes hätte sehr viel Zeit in Anspruch genommen. Bei der Laboranbindung ist aber eine geboten,
Daher haben wir Überlegungen einer Zusammenarbeit einvernehmlich zurückgestellt. Um das mal,
Einfach und leiden verständlich zu machen ist, es war wichtig, es musste schnell gehen, also haben wir es gelassen,
Knüller und und die KV Digital sagt, gleichwohl die KVB.
KBV ist.
Kasse ist nicht die Bundesvereinigung,
bereits zu Beginn der Gespräche ihre Vorstellung der Telekom transparent bekannt gemacht hatte, präsentierte die Telekom der KBV
erst mit erheblichem zeitlichen Verzug und dann mit erheblich anderen Vorstellungen ihre eigenen Vertragsentwürfe. Ähm,
genauen zu den genauen Differenzen wollte sie sich aber nicht äußern. Mit anderen Worten, die habe ich jetzt einfach gelassen.
Also am Ende sind es Vertragsprobleme.
Eine, eine, eine, eine binär Information über das Internet zu übertragen. Ich meine.
Könnte ja noch jeder kommt.
Ja, um nochmal diesen technischen Kontext klarzumachen. Alles, wovon wir reden, ist eine Information, die in einem ohnehin schon vollständig digitalen System vorliegt, muss per eines,
Ein Aufruf über das Internet, da muss ein ein Paket, ein Klick quasi irgendwo gemacht werden, auf einem anderen Server, der sagt, hier Ergebnis, danke, tschüss,
So, dann brauche ich noch nicht mal eine Antwort. Das ist alles. Ja. Oder fällt dir noch irgendwas ein über sehe ich irgendwas? Also.
Na, du musst du musst dir noch Gedanken darüber machen, dass dass das äh nur autorisierte.
Ja, Login und,
und Zertifikat-Pinning und so weiter, aber das sind einfach technische Details, die sind eigentlich gelöst und totale no Brainer. Am Ende geht es nur da drum. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe überhaupt gar nicht, wo man da jetzt klar irgendwie Verträge muss vielleicht da sein, aber was soll da schon groß drin stehen?
Vor allem kannst du dir ganz einfach sagen, ne, dann dann sagst du halt, hier pass auf, hier ist unser Skript.
Was schon mal auf jeder Plattform läuft, ja, welches Daten in einem bestimmten Format entgegennimmt,
und diese Daten an unsere APIs schickt und dabei mit einem Zertifikat eher einerseits sich selber authentifiziert, andererseits die Gegenstelle sicherstellt. So, jetzt.
Unser ist dank verschiedener Librarys in der Lage, die Daten in XML, Jason, CSV und PDF, von mir aus entgegenzunehmen, ja?
Und ein Fax Interface haben wir auch noch gemacht. So, ne. Ende der Geschichte.
Das ist wirklich absurd. Also es ist einfach das das kann mir einfach keiner erzählen, dass das eine Implementationsphase da länger als eine Woche dauern müsste. Das ist einfach Unsinn.
Absolut äh also ich kann es mir, ne, ach okay, ist aber jetzt so. Ist so. Ist jetzt so und.
Aber es gibt doch Anbindungen.
Es gibt Anwendungen, genau, er hat mir auch einen Arzt, glaube ich, drauf hingewiesen, dass jetzt teilweise die Labore wiederum auch ihre, die haben auch dann wieder Apps, die haben quasi auch ähm.
Die haben schon Interfaces für eine digitale Abholung oder Benachrichtigung mit anderen Worten, die haben die gehen auch mit Daten um.
Die auch übers Internet und in Apps rein und so weiter. Es ist alles überhaupt gar kein Thema. Das ist einfach vollkommen hanebüchen und.
Ist ja das Schöne an Standards, es gibt einfach so viele zur Auswahl und deswegen äh ha, ist das jetzt gescheitert. Mehr kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen. Äh das äh betrifft, wenn ich das jetzt richtig, ich weiß nicht genau, äh wie viele.
Labore, hier die äh KV digital äh.
Mit dem Kopf schütteln, was Teesistin regelmäßig hervorruft, ja? Könntest du wahrscheinlich mehrere tausend Privathaushalte das Jahr über mit Energie versorgen?
Mit Internet könntest du die.
Sogar das auch.
So, dann gibt's ein weiteres Problem mit der Corona-Warn-App.
Ähm und zwar auch das äh keins, was wir hier nicht ähm lange im voraus schon behandelt hätten. Und zwar die Sache, ne, die Messgenauigkeit.
Ähm.
Dieser Bluetooth-Abstandsmessung. Einerseits ist die Bluetooth-Biekentechnologie dafür gedacht,
Abstände grob über die Dämpfung, also die Schwächung der Signalstärke abschätzen zu können. Die Frage ist, wie genau kann sie das tatsächlich, ja? Die die ursprüngliche Idee der Anwendung ist ja,
eher so eine.
Zur, also du hast mehrere solche biegen, sondern kannst du dich am einfach dann musst du gar nicht den genauen Abstand schätzen zu einem biegen, sondern da du mehrere hast
kannst du einfach die relativen Signalstärken nehmen, um deine Position zu bestimmen. Das heißt, da erleichtert dir die die erleichtern dir diese mehreren Signale, dann,
eine einfachere und eine genauere Positionierung.
Bei der Corona-Warn-App ist jeder bieten einzeln und du hast die ehrenvolle Aufgabe, den Abstand zu schätzen. Und es gibt aber natürlich dabei so Schwierigkeiten wie
ist aus Wasser, ne, wenn der dazwischen ist,
hast du eine andere Empfangsstärke bei zwei Komma vier Gigahertz als wenn der nicht dazwischen ist und so weiter. Es gibt eine Reihe an Problemen.
Das war klar. Ähm deswegen hatte ja auch damals noch unter Planung der ähm der zentralen Lösung.
Dieses Konglomerat, Pep PT, sich Initial auch darum bemüht, ne,
Eine Lösung dafür zu finden, möglichst viele Messwerte zu finden, um eine äh den real Bedingungen angepasste ähm Schätzungen,
Bestenfalls vornehmen zu können. Es scheint, dass der größere Teil dieses Wissens zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht in die App eingeflossen ist.
Ähm zum Beispiel habe ich ja jetzt auch, auch das war etwas, was wir erwähnt hatten, ne. Es wäre mit mit unter Umständen gar nicht so blöd, wenn man der App auch sagen könnte, du pass mal auf, jetzt bin ich in die nächsten paar Stunden bin ich in einem Zug,
ändere vielleicht deine für die Erfassung entsprechend oder Tim träumt ja immer noch vom Stadionbesuch, ne? Ähm und so weiter und so fort. Ja, äh all das äh hat irgendwie nicht stattgefunden.
Und jetzt hat äh haben irische Forscherin vom Trinity College äh in Dublin
mal sich in eine Tram gesetzt und haben unter gleichen unter kontrollierten Bedingungen da mal Corona-Warn-App-Tests gemacht. Und zwar haben die sich
in gleichen Positionierungen.
Mit gleichen Geräten. Äh allerdings also immer das gleiche Gerät, um Unterschiede in der äh Bluetooth, Low Energy Ausstattung zu vermeiden und äh nur Android-Geräte.
In diese Tram gesetzt und haben sind damit rumgefahren, haben sich nachher die Ergebnisse angeschaut, was diese App da geliefert hat und haben gesagt, na ja, es gab tatsächlich Schwankungen der Signalstärke um mehr als zehn Dezibel, obwohl alle einfach nur an Ort und.
Ähm Stelle saßen. Und ähm kommen zu dem Ergebnis, unsere Messung hm zeigen an, dass es kaum bis.
Nur geringe bis keine Korrelation zwischen der Empfangsstärke und der tatsächlichen Distanz zwischen den Individuen kippt. Ähm,
Sie haben dann außerdem die detection Rolls, also die die Detektionsregeln der italienischen Schweizer und deutschen Apps verglichen und festgestellt, dass die,
Schweizer und Deutschen im Prinzip gar keine exposition
Exporter Notification triggern. Die haben also immer gesagt, hier ist mir keiner nahe gekommen, weil sie eben etwas höhere.
Schwellwerte hatten dafür zu sagen, mir ist jemand nah, während die italienischen zwar Meldungen ausgegeben haben.
Aber eine ähm.
Nur fünfzig Prozent True Positiv haben. Mit anderen Worten, deren Sensitivität ist.
Zwar hochgegangen, aber die ähm die Force genauso. Mit anderen Worten, es lag nicht an der Schwelle.
Sondern auch wenn du die Schwellen anders setzt, ist das Signal einfach nicht. Ähm tja, das ist äh.
Eine schlechte Nachricht erstmal für die Idee des Fahren im Zugs. Jetzt muss man aber sagen, das liegt daran, dass dieser Zug eben ein Metallkäfig ist. Und was du,
eigentlich gerne hättest, wäre das ähm dass du im Prinzip über alle alarmiert wirst, ne? Also.
Ich denke, dass das der Zug da als eine andere Situation wahrgenommen werden müsste, als das, was die Forscherinnen und Forscher hier nämlich sagen, dass sie die letztendlich halt sagen, okay, wir bleiben hier bei dieser ganzen Abstandssache und so,
Also, was gibt's für Auswege? Ich denke, einerseits hm,
dass man, dass die App Situation erkennt oder manuell beigebracht bekommt und dann eben unterschiedliche Schwellwerte heranzieht.
Oder unterschiedliche Modelle der Alarmierung oder dass man auch dieser Vorschlag kam schon von einigen äh Hörerinnen und Hörern auch in den Kommentaren, dass man für bestimmte Locations.
Spezifische Bieken setzt, die sich die App unter allen Umständen merkt. Ne, also dass du sagst, das Restaurant sendet einen spezifischen Biegen mit einem einen gleichbleibenden Biegen, mit einem bestimmten Bit, wo die App sagt, alles klar,
den speichere ich auf jeden Fall und zwar egal wie stark der jetzt war.
Nachteil ist, du hast ja hier keine Zwei-Wege-Authentifizierung, das heißt,
du könntest quasi diese Bea massenhaft fälschen und damit irgendwie Geräte zuballern, ja?
Ja, das ist äh hat nochmal so ein paar Gültigkeiten. Ich will nochmal kurz was zu dieser Bluetooth-Geschichte sagen. Dann können wir uns vielleicht auch nochmal drüber unterhalten, wie ähm ob ob hier unter Umständen auch einen Kurswechsel,
ähm nötig ist,
Jetzt ist es ja so, diese ganze Idee mit mir darf keiner zu nahe kommen und wenn ich jemanden, wenn jemand so und so lange neben mir steht, in einer bestimmten Zeit und, und, und Nähe, dann bin ich irgendwie gefährdet.
Das ja? Ja genau, genau. Das ist ja quasi eine Annahme von Anfang dieser Pandemie,
Und mittlerweile haben wir ja auch eine neue Erkenntnislage und wir haben halt gesehen,
Das Problem ist vor allem ein drinnen Problem. Ich glaube, es gibt so Faktor zwanzig zu eins, Infektionen äh Innenräume,
und ähm außen, muss man jetzt mal schauen, was,
diese Sommersaison jetzt sozusagen nochmal an ähm Erkenntnissen gibt, weil jetzt waren ja eigentlich viele Leute draußen, aber vielleicht waren halt einfach trotzdem auch Leute wieder
drin, weil sie sich in der Kantine aufgehalten haben. Restaurants et cetera. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Oder sie haben halt dann doch zu nah aneinander rumgesessen, obwohl's draußen war,
dann ist halt vielleicht auch was passiert und da hätte es ja dann auch theoretisch helfen können. Also ich glaube auch immer noch, dass das helfen kann, das mal ganz.
Diese ähm Geschichte mit der richtigen Einschätzung,
des Abstands ist im Übrigen auch ein durchaus bekanntes Problem und zwar ähm eigentlich auch nur bei Android,
hat damit zu tun, dass das Betriebssystem und die Telefone auf denen das Betriebssystem läuft ja nicht vom selben Hersteller sind und von daher relativ wenig Kenntnisse darüber Vorlagen, wie so die Radioeigenschaften dieser Geräte denn nun wirklich ganz konkret ist,
Ich habe ähm es gibt einerseits eine äh TU Berlin gab's eine Gruppe, die daran auch nochmal massiv geforscht hat und die auch so ein ähm,
äh Anmerkungen, also sehr, selber getestet, hart und auch Vorschläge gemacht hat, die auch teilweise übernommen worden sind und das auch bei Google mittlerweile Anpassungen vorgenommen worden sind. Das heißt, die,
Exposur Notification, das Framework, was über den Google Play Store ausgeliefert wird, auf den Android-Telefon, wo sich dann die Corona-Warn-App einklinkt.
Enthalten tatsächlich konkrete Profile für die einzelnen Telefone, die permanent aktualisiert,
Also es ist sozusagen auch ein Prozess, der im Idealfall sich laufend verbessert
weil über entsprechende Crowd-Sourcing und äh andere Forschungswege, äh diese Informationen halt jetzt erstmalig so in dieser Detailtiefe überhaupt erfasst worden sind
Aber trotzdem, gerade so Situationen wie Zug, et cetera, alles, was halt schlecht belüftet ist,
Da ist es dann irgendwo auch egal, ob jemand zehn Meter von dir wegsetzt äh oder so, da greift dann einfach dieser Faktor nicht. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, kann man entweder,
dass er so ein bisschen die Idee, die hinter diesem,
äh steckt, kann man dafür sorgen, dass die App eine Vorstellung davon hat, ob man sich in einem Innenraum befindet, also sozusagen in einem Ort erhöhter,
Bedrohung, sage ich mal, ja, ähm das könnte man ja dadurch äh quasi triggern. Ähm
und sie dann eben an eine andere Bewertung durchführt. Dieser äh vorliegenden Daten. Also was wir letztlich sehen,
fällt mir ein bisschen schwer jetzt auf dieses Konzept, dadurch äh groß reinzuhacken, ne, weil natürlich viele Leute so, ja, haben wir ja gleich gesagt, kann ja alles nichts bringen und äh wenn wir das zentrale System verwendet hätten, dann hätten wir ja viel mehr gewusst und so weiter, das ist Unsinn, weil diese Problematik betrifft jegliches Modell.
Ja, das ist äh genau das ist äh.
Wir,
Wir befinden uns in einem Prozess. Seit zwei Monaten laufen läuft die Corona-Warn-App und auch weltweit ist ja auch die Verbreitung ist ja auch nicht so, muss sagen, das habe ich etwas unterschätzt zum Beispiel, wie wenig die USA auf dieses Modell gegangen ist. Also da kommen jetzt erst.
In den ersten Staaten wirklich die Apps raus,
Das heißt, diese ganze Informationsgewinnung ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen eine europäische Geschichte. Wundert jetzt insofern nicht, als dass das ja auch alles von Europa aus angestoßen wurde von der Schweiz et cetera, Deutschland. Aber trotzdem hätte ich mir äh,
gedacht, gerade wo die Krise so stark ist in USA, ja äh und die Leute ja auch, sagen wir mal, etwas,
anderes Verhältnis zu dieser ganzen Datenschutzdiskussion haben im im Mittel
das etwas schneller vorangehen würde. Ist nun mal nicht passiert und deswegen findet das jetzt noch statt. Und ich vermute, wir werden da auch noch neue Vorschläge bekommen, wie sich das Ganze
verbessern lässt. Ich sage das jetzt deshalb, weil ich jetzt auch nicht so die Botschaft rausgeben will, das hat jetzt alles nichts gebracht,
sondern das kann immer noch hilfreich sein, kann, kann auch sein, dass wir am Ende feststellen, dass wir für nichts ausschlaggebend. Trotzdem.
Mittlerweile gibt's siebzehn Komma zwei Millionen Downloads.
An der Stelle müsste man vielleicht auch nochmal eine andere Kritik äh machen, weil was mich wirklich ein bisschen stört ist, man hat zwar jetzt diese Corona-Warn-App,
an diesem Punkt gebracht, der ursprünglich geplant war, aber jetzt habe ich so den Eindruck, tut sich konzeptionell nicht so viel.
Ja, das ist das ist der Fehler, ja.
Also es bedarf einfach einer einer fortwährenden,
Überdenkung, ob man denn richtig vorgeht und eine entsprechende Anpassung. Ich bin mir sicher, dass es auch Leute gibt, die sich darüber Gedanken machen, aber so der Fokus ist halt äh nicht so sehr da drauf. Und äh hier muss,
umgeschaltet werden. Und ich denke, man kann auch von anderen Apps lernen, zum Beispiel die schweizer App, wenn ich mich jetzt grad nicht vertue, doch das ist, glaube ich, die Schweizer App, die also auch auf dem selben System basiert, zeigt in der App an,
Wie viele Leute diese App benutzen? So eine Information gibt es in Deutschland überhaupt nicht. Es gibt nur die Zahl, wie viele Leute haben sie heruntergeladen.
Gut, wenn ich die jetzt auf zwei meiner Devices runterlade, sind das halt schon mal zwei Downloads, ne, und Download heißt ja nicht, sie ist auch wirklich aktiv. Diese Information kann mühelos aus den,
dem Betrieb heraus gewonnen werden, ohne dass man da eine Anonymität äh preisgibt und ich verstehe halt zum Beispiel nicht, warum sowas nicht gemacht wird, um einfach mehr Wellness zu äh schaffen, um das Ding weiter zu pushen.
Ich denke, was man zu dieser Studie sagen muss, also mir ist vor allem aufgefallen, was die nicht gemacht haben, ne. Die haben alle ihre Experimente, haben die in dieser Tram gemacht und sie haben keinen Vergleich geschaffen, was sie, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe
zu einer Situation in Innenräumen oder draußen, ja? Weil was was im im Prinzip ein
einen offenen Faktor lässt, weil sie sagen zwar, okay, in dieser Tram in Dublin hat das Ding jetzt
nicht funktioniert, zumindest nicht so, wie es sollte. Ja, jetzt wäre der Punkt gewesen, hätte es denn außerhalb der Trump funktioniert, da gehe ich eigentlich davon aus, dass sie da Daten haben, die haben sie aber hier nicht in Verhältnis gesetzt,
Ja, hätte ja auch sein können, dass sie sagen, funktioniert ohnehin nicht mit den Telefonen, die wir hier haben. Hätte ja auch sein können. Und.
Ähm der andere Punkt ist, den du grade gesagt hast, den würde ich hier an dieser Stelle nur nochmal betonen wollen, nämlich dass ähm.
Die Situation Zug, es könnte nun sein, dass das.
Zwar die App nicht wie Respekt und Advit heißt funktioniert aber es könnte auch sein, dass es für die Situation die adäquate,
Reaktion ist, da da du nämlich in diesem Zug,
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen genug Luft hast, ne? Das wäre also quasi dieses Ausversehen gut ist, dass es nicht funktioniert, ne? Und diese Dinge gehören viel mehr erforscht und da hätte man sich ähm,
irgendwie viel, viel mehr Bewegung gewünscht, als die jetzt irgendwie nach dem einmaligen Release dieser App stattgefunden hat,
So und das, denke ich, ist genau das, was du ja auch gerade schon gesagt hast, so die äh man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
dass ähm als die App dann released war, alle sich einmal in die Hände äh geklatscht haben und dann weitergezogen sind. Und das war von vorneherein klar, dass das nicht so gehen würde,
Ähm.
Das zeigt sicher auch bei dieser Telekom-Geschichte, weil dann einfach der Druck nicht mehr.
Genau, da ist jetzt genau das ist jetzt komm, scheiß drauf.
Bei der SAP hat so viel richtig gemacht und jetzt ist dabei.
Zu sich gesagt, so, oh, da haben wir aber, da können wir uns aber, das reicht erstmal für einen Monat.
Ey, die Lorbeeren nehmen wir, die legen wir bei uns auf den Grill.
Da kann man auch, da können wir erstmal längere Zeit zehren. Ähm allerdings auch.
Und ich denke, darüber hatten wir auch noch nicht gesprochen. Haben wir darüber gesprochen oder nicht? Über die Probleme bei der Hintergrundaktualisierung.
Nein, haben wir noch nicht.
Ja, weil dann müssen wir das nämlich auch nochmal erwähnen. Das war und da muss ich sagen, da sind wir dann in dem Bereich, wo man sehr scharfe Kritik üben muss.
Und äh das betrifft die Probleme bei der Hintergrundaktualisierung. Ich habe hier in der Sendung auch öfter schon gesagt, dass,
Ich mich wundere, dass die ganze Zeit immer nur die Anzahl der Downloads berichtet wurde, können ja Leute sein, die sich die zweimal installiert haben, in ein neues Handy gekauft haben oder sonstwas, ne.
Und vor allem, nicht jeder, der es downloadet, hat die App ja potenziell auch tatsächlich aktiviert. Deswegen immer wenn ich gefragt wurde,
In den Presseanfragen, insbesondere an den Cars Computerclub, habe ich gesagt, geht zu den Unternehmen hin,
Fragt die, wie viele Unique Zugriffe in einem freiwählbaren vierundzwanzig Stunden Zeitraum, sie auf die Server haben, wo die,
Liste der veröffentlichten Codes heruntergeladen werden, weil die App macht das nur,
Einmal alle vierundzwanzig Stunden, wenn du es manuell triggerst, dann sacht, kommt da ein Counter und die sagt, in vierundzwanzig Stunden darfst du wieder triggern.
Das heißt, in einem freiwählbaren Zeitraum von vierundzwanzig Stunden werden alle aktiv genutzten Apps dort,
anfragen. Und diese Zahl wird unter den siebzehn Millionen liegen, die gerade berichtet werden. Und zwar, weil einige vielleicht die App auch wieder runtergeworfen haben und so weiter und so fort. Ganz klare Frage, das ist der Wert, auf den die hätten gucken müssen.
Und dann kommt mit sehr starker Verspätung die Meldung,
dass eine, dass es bei zwei Herstellern mit so unbedeutenden Namen wie Samsung und ähm Huawei.
Probleme gab mit der Hintergrundaktualisierung. So, jetzt ist das so ein Handy ist in der Tasche und ähm.
Der Grund, warum diese Akkus einen Tag halten, ist primär, dass diese Geräte ein sehr, sehr radikal gegen jede Form von Hintergrundaktivität vorgehen. Ne, die verhindern.
Ähm was weiß ich, dass das irgendwelche Apps im Hintergrund großartig downloaden, die verhindern, dass irgendwelche Apps im Hintergrund großartige Berechnungen anstellen, die verhindern, dass irgendwelche Apps irgendwie großartig Daten uploaden? Das hat
viele Gründe, auch für Privatsphäre und so weiter hat das auch Vorteile, aber es hat vor allem den zentralen Grund, dass der Akku bitte, bitte durch den Tag hält.
Ja? Und,
da sind die natürlich äh äußerst ähm äußerst streng. Die Möglichkeiten des Betriebssystemes hier die Apps zu beschneiden. Das hat viele Vorteile. Hat aber natürlich einen Nachteil für eine App, die,
davon abhängt, einmal am Tag sich diese Dinger runterzuladen, nämlich diese Codes. Und jetzt war es offenbar so, dass auf dem Android äh in dem Android Bereich.
Diese beiden Hersteller Samsung und ähm Huawei noch mal selber geklöppelte.
Stromspeermechanismen hatten, die über den Android Standard hinaus Apps, die Hintergrundaktualisierungen,
verbieten. Was dazu geführt hat, wenn du diese App auf einem der am Telefon dieser Hersteller hattest, dann ist nach ein paar Tagen.
Dieser ähm hat dieser Prozess angeschlagen und hat der App die Hintergrundaktualisierung verboten. Das bedeutet,
Hast keine Notifications mehr bekommen? Und du hättest auch irgendwie, ne, über ein Testergebnis wärst du im Zweifelsfall nicht alarmiert worden.
Bist du dir sicher mit, weil hat auch gar kein Playstore und von daher auch gar nicht die Corona-Warn-App.
Die Älteren doch schon.
Okay, das mag sein, ja.
Ähm und das war ein Problem, was.
Und da war jetzt die Berichterstattung, na ja, also die Journalistin, ich oder der Journalist haben dann verlinkt auf ein Gitterpechow, wo irgendwie,
Leute mit allen möglichen Geräten sagen, ja, irgendwie bei mir aktualisiert sich das nicht im Hintergrund. Und sagte, das Problem ist seit
zwei Wochen bekannt. Wo ich jetzt sage, na ja, da ist dieser Gitt-Up Echo, dafür war der zu bunt, da waren zu viele drin, die sich darüber beschwert haben, ne. Aber das Problem muss
sich in den Zugriffszahlen auf diese Server gezeigt haben. Und das Problem war vielleicht nicht wegen des Gitterbisches, aber auch wegen des Gitter-Ischis und wegen der Zugriffszahlen auf den Server mit Sicherheit bekannt. Und hier wäre eine Sache ganz
einfach gewesen, zu sagen, mit der Hintergrundaktualisierung über mehrere Tage ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Aufruf an die Nutzerinnen der App. Guckt mal einmal am Tag rein.
Oder alle zwei und drück mal manuell den Knopf und stellt mal sicher, dass das funktioniert, wir arbeiten dran, das sicherzustellen. Und das haben die nicht getan. Das war dann irgendwie so eine Freitag Abend Bild-Zeitungsmeldung hier auf Android tut das nicht.
Und dann kam, äh ich glaube, zwei Tage später oder drei Tage später, die Meldung, auf iOS hatten sie auch, diese Probleme. Und hier ist wieder, dass diese Probleme auftreten würden.
Wahr abzusehen. Im Hintergrund längere Zeit auf so einem Gerät aktiv zu sein, ist eine Herausforderung. Kann dir jeder
Entwickler, jede Entwicklerin von Epson Lied von singen, ne? Wenn man jetzt irgendwie die Podcast-Apps zum Beispiel haben auch das Problem, wenn die längere Zeit nicht aufgemacht wurden, dann können die nicht mehr im Hintergrund die Megabyte oder Gigabytes ein Podcast runterladen. Das ist ein bekanntes Problem, das hätte allen klar sein müssen,
und es war zu erwarten, dass man da vor allem mit irgendwelchen selbstgeklopppelten Lösungen der Hersteller in dem.
Ja doch sehr balkanisierten äh Android-Ökosystem Probleme bekommt. Das die ja der Kritikpunkt ist, damit wurde nicht umgegangen und nicht proaktiv. Und da haben sie sich dann zwei ähm,
zurecht zwei große äh Negativpunkte einfahren können, nämlich einmal, dass äh dass es auf Android nicht funktionierte und wenn wir hier von Samsung und Huawei reden, reden wir von fünfundsiebzig Prozent Marktanteil oder sowas, ne. Ähm.
Und dann kurz danach auch noch das bei
bei Apple, dass die Probleme auftauchen, ich sage das immer, wer Software macht, weiß, die ist nie fertig, die hat immer Probleme, die äh der verantwortungsvolle
Konzern unterscheidet sich von dem anderen dadurch, dass wieder mit umgegangen wird. Und der Umgang mit diesem Problem äh hat nicht stattgefunden.
Genau, ist die Frage, wie man jetzt hier die passenden Bohmänner äh zu mailen sollte.
Es ist ja nun mal so, diese App ist offiziell eine App des RKI.
Und das Problem ist so ein bisschen, dass äh haben wir ja auch aus diesem ganzen Umgang mit Daten, Material, äh et cetera schon gelernt,
ganz in der digitalen Welt ist das RKI auch noch nicht angekommen, das hatten wir ja schon mit der Datenspende, also man hat schon eben gemerkt, wie so diese typische deutsche Unhäufenheit ähm sich dort auch abgezeichnet hat,
Stück weit kann ich das eben auch verstehen oder sagen wir mal, habe ich zumindest ein gewisses Verständnis, nur,
Das Ding ist, man muss halt so ein Projekt auch wirklich ernsthaft betreiben und nicht nur so
Ja, okay, jetzt haben wir das mal gemacht und jetzt ist doch fertig und jetzt seid doch mal ruhig. So und dann jetzt warten wir mal, dass das so magisch von sich aus heraus äh Ergebnisse liefert. Nein, da braucht's einfach ein fokussiertes Team, was einfach nichts anderes macht, als.
Permanent darüber Gedanken zu machen, ja, ist das noch das, was unsere Kunden wollen, ja?
Die Kunden sind quasi die Gesundheit dieser Gesellschaft. Und äh dass man da aktiv drüber nachdenkt. Ich.
Weiß es jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, ich habe auch so den Eindruck gewonnen, nachdem äh die Hauptarbeit dann geleistet war, sind diese Teams.
Nachvollziehbarerweise auch ein bisschen äh verkleinert worden. Natürlich arbeiten da Leute noch dran, aber,
es braucht einfach eine Dynamik und es braucht in der Regel aber auch eine Dynamik aus der Entwicklung heraus, wo die Leute selber auch solche Sachen feststellen und wo die Möglichkeit haben zu sagen, okay, meiner Meinung nach müssten wir diesen,
radikalen Move machen, wie zum Beispiel eben jetzt dieses äh aktuelle Installation, zählen, was ja,
hat, ne? Da muss äh geschrieben werden, da müssen Systeme angepasst werden, es muss abgenommen werden, bla, bla, bla. RKI muss es eben auch äh decken und das
scheint mir so in dieser Form derzeit nicht zu existieren, zumindest nicht in dem Maße, wie es angemessen wäre.
Ja. Na ja, sie haben dann, sie haben dann irgendwann ein ein Update rausgegeben, aber ne.
Es gibt wohl noch mit einzelnen Andrés gibt's wohl noch Probleme aus denen von dir auch schon genannten äh Sachen, dass da einfach,
Dinge passieren, weil eben Anpassungen an Android, die man so nicht äh sieht, wenn man mit diesem Telefon nicht testet. Es ist unmöglich für einen Android-Entwickler-Team heutzutage alle Plattformen zu testen. Ja. Ja, es, es ist, es ist sehr wohl möglich.
Alle iPhones, die Apple jemals verkauft hat, äh zu testen, auf denen es läuft, weil das ist eine recht überschaubare Zahl, das sind vielleicht so fünf, sechs.
Plus Varianten davon. Ja. Ähm tja ähm so ist es halt.
Wir bleiben noch ein bisschen bei Corona-Datensammlungen, ne.
Ja auch schön.
Eine Datensammlung, die ja zum Glück an den meisten Orten.
Dezentral noch noch stattfindet, ja? Ähm und sogar nicht digital, ist das Anfertigen von Corona-Kontaktlisten Orten,
des öffentlichen Zusammentreffens, insbesondere gastronomischen Betrieben, Bars und Restaurants. Ähm,
einige Gastronominnen im Freundeskreis habe, die mir dann schildern, dass,
brauchen sie mir auch gar nicht zu schildern, das sieht man auch, dass es dann auch zum Beispiel Leute gibt, die sagen, wat, ich soll mich hier eintragen, dann gehe ich woanders hin,
wo man sich fragt, wo gehst denn du hin? Das ist eine Auflage, die können das nach meinem Verständnis nicht zulässig, das nicht zu tun.
Kann sein, dass ich da falsch liege. Es ist auf jeden Fall wahrscheinlich äh ziemlich dumm, das nicht zu tun. Und es ist wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich dumm, sich dort nicht einzutragen.
Weil letzten Endes würde ich ja so das Versprechen dieser Kontaktlisten eine für mich doch recht relevante Information bekommen,
wenn sich herausstellen sollte, dass dieses Etablessement von einer infizierten Person besucht oder äh betrieben wurde,
in dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich da die Spülwasserreste äh im Bierglas hatte, ja? Und ähm das ist äh.
Schon eine relativ sinnvolle Idee, das zu tun. Funktioniert aber natürlich nur, wenn die Leute motiviert sind, da richtige Daten anzugeben. Und,
Wenn ich irgendwie einige Läden sehe, die da quasi Papier sparen,
Unser offener DIN A4-Seite zwanzig Leute sich eintragen lassen mit Name, Adresse, Telefonnummer, E-Mail und so weiter. Dann habe ich auch nur schmalen schmales Interesse mich da einzutragen,
Und wenn ich dann noch lese, dass in Bremen, Hessen, Rheinland-Pfalz, Saarland und Hamburg ähm und in Bayern auf diese Listen im Rahmen polizeilicher Maßnahmen zugegriffen wurde.
Dann habe ich gar keinen Bock mich mehr, gar keinen Bock mehr, mich da einzutragen. Und ähm das,
ist auch wieder herzlich willkommen in Deutschland, ne, wo ein Schwein, äh wo ein wo ein Trog ist, da kommen die Schweine,
und sei es nur eine lose Zettelsammlung,
in den äh in den gastronomischen Betrieben, wo dann sofort irgendwie die Polizei ankommt und sagt, her damit, ja? Und das nimmt einem ja wirklich jeden Spaß. Der nimmt einen ja jeden Spaß, sich in so eine Liste einzutragen. Übrigens wollte ich hier an dieser Stelle nochmal die.
Anleitung erklären, wie man so etwas macht,
zwar geht man pro Person oder Tisch oder Gruppe nur einen Zettel, damit ich nicht die Telefonnummer von dem Typen am Nebentisch, an den anderen Tisch gebe,
ähm man lässt die Leute sich dort eintragen mit,
Ich denke, eine Kontaktmöglichkeit reicht, diese sollte natürlich hoffentlich funktionieren. Äh das liegt aber im Verantwortungsbereich dieser Person. Danach kommt dieser Zettel in eine Art Urne, wo einfach sichergestellt ist, dass der da nicht offen am Tisch rumliegt. Ähm.
Und am Ende des Tages kommt diese Uhr in einen Umschlag. Der Umschlag wird versiegelt, wird ein Datum drauf geschrieben. Und wenn vierzehn Tage ähm oben sind, wird dieser Umschlag mit in den Pizzaofen geworfen.
Drops ist gelutscht. So stelle ich mir das vor und so weise ich auch, dass das zum Beispiel in mehreren äh Spaces des Chaos-Computerclubs gehandhabt wird. Ja?
Ähm für diejenigen, die keinen Bock haben, da ihre E-Mail-Adresse anzugeben, wäre mein einfachster Rat, geht zu irgend so einem Wegwerf-E-Mail-Anbieter,
registriert euch deine Adresse und leitet von der Adresse, richtet von der Adresse eine Weiterleitung an eure richtige ein.
Hast du schnell gemacht, das kann jetzt zehn Minuten deines Lebens kann das kosten
Michi Punkt Corona dreiundzwanzig at Web DE mit einer Weiterleitung an deine richtige Adresse und den Mist kannst du hinschreiben wo du willst. Und wenn dann da irgendwann der der.
Ankommt, dann äh ich weiß ja damit umzugehen.
Ich hätte da ja noch eine andere Übung.
Oha. Zu Hause bleiben.
Nee, also ich meine, das Problem,
Also erstmal muss man auch sagen, ich kenne auch eine ganze Menge äh Restaurants, insbesondere so Schnellrestaurants, ähm wo zwar im Prinzip diese Anmeldepflicht auch existiert, wo sie aber einfach de facto nicht wahrgenommen wird. Dann hast du teilweise eben auch so digitale Lösungen, wo da so ein QR-Code ist, wo eine Webseite aufgeht, wo du dann deine
Adresse erreicht ganz schlechte Idee
Macht sowieso dann auch keiner, aber äh so und das so ein bisschen das Problem, es ist mal wieder zu kompliziert und es hat eben aus verschiedenen, also erstmal,
machen, dann oh wem gebe ich jetzt meine Daten, gehen die da jetzt mit ordentlich um? Antwort wahrscheinlich nicht
was muss ich da jetzt überhaupt drauf schreiben? Warum muss ich so viel hinterlassen? Und dann natürlich so Rahmenprobleme wie ich weiß nicht so als als
Frau kann ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass man dann irgendwie äh extreme äh Probleme hatte, einfach so,
die Daten, nachdem man sowieso die ganze Zeit gefragt wird und die man nicht rausgeben will an irgendwelche Leute, ja, dann auf einmal so niederschreibt und dann Stalking, keine Ahnung, was für Konsequenzen daraus dann äh vielleicht auch noch drohen.
Stellt sich die Frage, gäbe es nicht vielleicht irgendwie eine App.
Die alle sowieso schon dabei haben sollten, die so ein Notifizierungssystem im Falle von es gibt ein Problem irgendwie vorsieht, war da nicht gerade was, haben wir da nicht gerade über irgendwas gesprochen.
Ja, man könnte das machen.
Warum baut man sowas nicht in diese Corona-Warn-App ein, dass man sagt, okay, ich muss mich hier mal einchecken, dann wird da irgendwie so ein QR-Code äh angezeigt, den kann man entweder abscannen lassen
oder so dass es quasi, wenn das digital möglich ist, eingesammelt wird oder man kriegt so ein, was weiß ich, zwölf Buchstaben immer vier Zeichen mit Bindestrich getrennt, so ein Code, den schreibt man da drauf,
Niemand weiß, wer das ist und im Falle einer Kontaktverfolgung, die vom Gesundheitsamt angestrebt wird, kann man diesen Code einfach in das System geben und so, wie man von einem,
Test benachrichtigt wird, kann diese App auch sagen, ach übrigens, ruf mal Gesundheitsamt an, da ist was, äh können Sie dich interessieren,
würde so erstens dazu beitragen, dass mehr Leute diese App installieren, weil auf einmal hat sie wirklich einen täglichen Nutzen, du würdest sie die ganze Zeit benutzen und sie würde dir eine ganze Menge ersparen
und äh dementsprechend wäre er natürlich dann auch der Indips überhaupt zu haben und zu betreiben sehr viel größer. Also Win-win-win-win-Win. Aber da denkt halt wahrscheinlich mal wieder überhaupt keiner drüber nach über solche Szenar.
Unsere Hörerinnen schon, ich habe von vielen Leuten E-Mails bekommen, die äh also andere Vorstellungen hatten, irgendwie so man könnte ja an jedem Tisch ein äh,
ein Handy von dem Restaurant legen oder so, ne? Brauchst du alles gar nicht, ne? Äh QR-Code des Tages oder ähm hier ähm
nimmst halt eine NFC-Karte, die du kurz kennst, irgendwas, ne, irgendeine ID, dieses äh dieser gastronomischen Institution
die dann nachher in der Lage ist zu sagen OK wir hatten ein Vorfall in dem Zeitraum und dann geht die entsprechende machst das über die gleiche Notification wie sonst auch.
Das Ding hast du am Whiteboard in einer viertel Stunde mit Buntstiften hingemalt und danach schreibst du ein paar Zeilencode dafür und bist durch, ne? Und dann kannst du das äh vom Gesundheitsamt.
Die die QR-Codes sehen. Alles gar kein Problem, alles gar kein Problem, ne? Kannst.
Und die ganze Transparenzdiskussion wäre auch wieder locker abgefangen, weil ist dann alles wieder auf Gitarb und kann öffentlich eingesehen werden und.
Ja und vor allem halte ich das auch für die gerade in im Bereich gastronomischer Betriebe, die äh korrekte Vorgehensweise, weil sagen wir mal so, ich hätte jetzt von der wenn die App mir sagt, hier irgendwie ähm.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, ich wäre in einer Kneipe,
Ich sitze draußen auf der einen Seite der Terrasse und auf der anderen Seite der Terrasse sitzt eine infizierte Person,
dieser infizierten Person begegne ich im Laufe des Abends kaum, die speichelt aber in das gleiche Spülwasser wie ich. So und,
Ähm das heißt, dass die App diese Sache erfasst, ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich, während.
Ähm ne, dass ich nämlich jetzt hier mit den äh der äh mit den Schwellwerten der App äh diese über diese Person alarmiert werde, ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich, wenn die Person jetzt auch noch irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Keinen kein Bock hat äh oder keine Erinnerungen hat daran, dass sie in diesem in dieser Bar war oder so was oder denkt mit der App ist alles getan, dann erfahre ich da keine Notification. Ich würde sehr viel mehr. Also wenn ich,
in einem gastronomischen Betrieb war, wo am gleichen Tag eine Person mit,
mit Auswurf war, dann möchte ich das wissen und zwar unerheblich, ob ich der Person nahe gekommen bin oder nicht.
Und das wäre das ist ja das, was genau mit diesen Listen abgedeckt werden soll und das kriegen wir gerade auch wieder. Kriegen wir auch gerade wieder verkackt.
Und da hast du natürlich dann auch noch die, die, die Spezialistin, die dir dann irgendwie vortragen, dass sie
dass sie eine Datenerfassung auf Zellen dramatisch finden und da muss ich dann genau das eigentlich nicht, ne. Du könntest ja sogar, wenn die äh hier meinen Vorschlag mit den Umschlägen, kannst ja sogar noch ergänzen und sagen, pass auf Leute, wenn ihr
Wenn ihr Angst habt, dass wir hier auf die Zettel gucken, dann liegen da vorne auch nochmal Umschläge, könnt ihr euch einen Umschlag nehmen,
Ja, dann dann schreibt er auf euren Umschlag selber, euer Datum drauf oder was auch immer, ne, damit hier unser unser lüsternder Kellner,
euch abends nicht auf der Liste hat, wo nach Feierabend sich nochmal meldet.
Ich stell's mir halt schöner vor. Ich meine man könnte so eine Corona äh Warn App äh Erfassungs,
Also vielleicht nicht der Name, aber sozusagen so so Corona ähm melde, Pflichtapp rausgeben, ja, die eigentlich nichts anderes ist, als so einen QR-Codescanner von der CBA und dann kann halt hier äh macht man einfach die CBA auf,
Anzeigen. Wir kennen das ja immer schön hier und wenn man mit äh arbeitet,
ist das so eine gängige Tätigkeit, so zeigst du mir äh deins, dann zeige ich dir meins und so. In dem Fall zeigt man dann nur seins und,
mach kurz piep und man kann das ja sogar extrem machen, dass man auch sagt, es gibt hier einen Eingangsscanner,
und Ausgangsgener, da hast du auch die Zeit gleich miterfasst, also.
Es muss nur wieder, ne, dass hier haben wir aber leider die gleiche Debatte, wie bei der Corona-Warn-App. Das System muss halt dezentral gebaut werden, damit sie Leute nutzen wollen und was wir stattdessen sehen, ist das,
diese ganzen ähm Gastronomie, full Serviceanbieter ähm mal schnell,
irgendwelche, ja, Corona-Kontaktliste klöppeln wir euch auch noch in das System bauen und du dann da auf einmal irgendwelche zentralen Daten äh Haltungen hast, unter ähm unklarer ähm,
unter unklaren Verhältnissen, ne? Das ist das, was wir dann haben, statt die schönen Sachen.
Aber wir müssen uns auch noch über den Twitter-Hack kurz unterhalten.
Lustig.
Ist auch schon wieder ein paar Tage her, aber plötzlich,
twitterten so relativ ähm reichweitenstarke Accounts wie der von Elon Musk ähm.
Biden, ja, ich war nicht auch Warren Buffet oder sowas. Äh Bill Gates oder wer also reichweitenstarke äh äh Twitter-Accounts.
Äh Twitter in so was wie ähm ich habe entschieden, dass ich jetzt der Community etwas zurückgeben möchte,
und für die nächste halbe Stunde,
Äh machen wir das so, wenn du äh ich mache einen Bitcoin, wenn du an folgendes Bitcoin-Konto einen Betrag überweist, sende ich dir das das Doppelte zurück.
Gilt aber nur für die nächste halbe Stunde, also beeilt euch. Eine, also auch wirklich nicht vorstellen kann,
wie man so etwas glaubt, ja, dass Elon Musk freiwillig irgendwas irgendjemanden geben würde, noch dazu in Bitcoin, noch dazu das Doppelte, also eine eine absolut die die unglaubwürdigste und,
Dümmste Idee, die man haben kann, wenn man die Kontrolle über den Account von.
Ich kenne da sogar Leute aus meinem Umfeld, die auf sowas schon vor längerer Zeit mal reingefallen sind.
Ja, dann musst du dir halt aus deinem Umfeld entfernen.
Ja, das ähm.
Wie das immer so ist. Es gibt so Freunde, die machen manchmal auch Unfug, aber man muss sie trotzdem lieb haben.
Du musst sie halt einfach von deinem Portemonnaie fernhalten, sagen wir's so.
Ja.
Weil ähm zu dem äh also während dieses Angebot natürlich äh zu schön ist, um wahr zu sein, muss man natürlich sagen, wenn das jetzt von einem verify Twitter-Account einer äh Person von.
Internationaler Bekanntheit kommt, das ist natürlich so das Glaubwürdigste, was du machen kannst, für für derartige Scherze. Ähm und immerhin hat,
Die Angreiferin oder der der Angreifer in dem Fall damit, ich glaube, irgendwas zwischen hundertfünfzig und zweihunderttausend Euro eingenommen, je nachdem, wie der Bitcoin-Kurs gerade bewertet wird. Hatte dann aber auch äh wenige Tage später schon äh die
Verfolgungsbehörden vor der Tür und ist soweit ich das inzwischen sehe wendig geständig dann zumindest durch mehrere Zeugenaussagen belastet.
Und was sich da hinter verbirgt, war natürlich die Frage, okay, wie hat es jemand geschafft, diese ganzen Accounts unter seine Kontrolle zu bringen? Stellt sich raus,
Twitter hatte so einen, also natürlich, jeder jede Plattform braucht irgendwo so ein Admin Interface, in dem halt einfach alles geht,
und dieses Admin bei Twitter hat,
Ähm ungefähr eintausend Personen hatten darauf Zugriff und äh diese Schätzung ungefähr eintausend kommt daher, dass die in einem Slack-Kanal waren,
wo Nutzername, Passwort für diesen Zugang oben gepinnt waren als Message of the day,
und dieser der Angreifer stammte aus einer Szene, die sich für besondere Twitter-Accounts interessiert, insbesondere diejenigen, mit wenigen Zeichen.
Und ähm daher äh steht's,
Äh steht es Interesse daran haben, wie man denn in Twitter ins Adminface kommt? Ja und ich mein, so so einfältig wie dieses Interesse an Twittercause mit einstelligen Zeichen ist, äh so so einfältig war dann eben auch die Idee,
diesen Zugriff auszunutzen für diesen Bitcoin wo man.
Froh sein kann, weil er hätte auch die Kontrolle über den Twitter-Account von Donald Trump gehabt und mit dem.
Bin ich mir nicht so sicher? Meinst du nicht? Ich hab's nur Vermutungen gehört, aber offensichtlich scheint's da nochmal eine.
Kann sein, dass sie.
Besondere Sicherung zu geben.
Ähm davon merkt man nichts, weil dieser Account ja trotzdem ein ein schön nach dem anderen von sich.
Ja. Ja, nicht die Art von Sicherung, die wie sie uns vorschwebt, sondern halt nur.
Sagen wir mal so, mit wenn du den Twitter-Account von Elon Musk kontrollierst, kannst du damit auf jeden Fall einen größeren Schaden anrichten als hundertfünfzigtausend Euro.
Unter Garantie, also da hätte man allein schon durch Aktien wahrscheinlich mehr Geld verdienen können et cetera.
Ne, da hätte also allein die richtigen Aktien zu sorten äh hätte da äh viel helfen können, aber okay,
Egal. Ähm oder sei es auch nur die Twitter-Aktien zu zu äh zu shorten, aber egal, egal. Ähm,
dass die Katastrophe eigentlich hier ist, dass offenbar die
für so ein Panel in irgendeinem Slackkanal rumhängen und du nur,
eine angestellte Person bei Twitter irgendwie mittels Social Engineering übernehmen musstest, um Blick in diesen Snack-Kanal werfen zu können. Und wenn, da muss man wirklich da ist Twitter.
Tatsächlich, ob wir das wollen oder nicht, eine kritische Infrastruktur für die internationalen Beziehungen,
und das Wirtschaftssystem und dass da die Credentials in irgendeinen Slack-Kanal hängen, stimmt ähm mich.
Etwas verstimmt mich.
Ja, da würde einen natürlich auch interessieren, inwiefern das quasi jetzt
wirklich Firmenrasen war, zu der zu dem Zeitpunkt oder ob die Admin äh Abteilung da nicht einfach eigene Strukturen entwickelt hat, von der so keiner so richtig was wusste. In beiden Fällen ist es natürlich äh falsch und scheiße und muss verhindert werden, aber,
solche Geschichten sind ja meistens dann immer relativ einfach.
Also schon mal von vorne herein für solche Zugänge nicht. Ja? Ohne zweiter Faktor solche Zugänge nicht.
Klar. Ohne zweiter Faktor. Das muss ja so kommt das muss ja auch nicht explizit erlaubt gewesen sein, aber es ist halt auch nicht nennenswert in Forstwort so oder so.
Dafür machst du zweite Faktoren, ja, damit die Leute, die nicht auch noch teilen, ja, aber okay.
Das hätte so nicht sein dürfen und jede von diesen tausend Personen hätte spätestens dann, wo sie das sieht, sagen sollen,
Ist das das Beste, was wir gemeinsam zu schaffen, in der Lage sind,
oder können wir hier nach höherem Streben.
Das wäre das ist offenbar bei Twitter nicht in der Unternehmenskultur. Also wir haben Glück gehabt.
Wir waren ja gerade schon bei so schön bei illegalen Datenzugriffen äh der Polizei auf die Corona-Daten. Ähm es ist ja ein äh dann auch noch ein weiteres Problemfeld, was wir hier haben, nämlich der Zugriff auf die Polizeidatenbanken.
Ähm seit etwas mehr als zwei Jahren treibt hier in Deutschland eine Person oder mehrere ihr Unwesen mit Drohmails an ähm.
Ja Personen, die sich nicht in der Öffentlichkeit als stramme Faschistinnen zu erkennen geben.
Ähm die Liste der Zielpersonen ist lang. Ich kann das gar nicht mehr alles äh vortragen, aber ähm,
in Hessen hat das äh spezifisch äh betroffen ähm Seda, Yildiz. Ähm.
Die die Familie von vertreten hat, dem ersten Mordopfer der Terrorgruppe,
die sich nationalsozialistischer Untergrund genannt hat oder immer noch nennt. Ähm die hessische Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken, Jasmin Wissler und die Kabarettistin,
und in diesen drei Fällen stammten die Daten, die hier diese NSU-Drommails verwendet haben.
Aus Datenabfragen, die über äh diese Datenbanken der Polizei Hessen,
stattgefunden haben. Mit anderen Worten, wir haben eine Verbindung zwischen einer Gruppe, die sich in der Nachfolge einer rechtsterroristischen Vereinigung sieht und der hessischen Polizei.
Jetzt fragt man sich, wie sind denn da eigentlich so die Gegebenheiten bei der Datenabfrage aus solchen Polizeidatenbanken? Tja, äh seit zweitausendachtzehn gab es in mehr als vierhundert Fällen Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Polizeibedienstete, die hier
unrechtmäßige Zugriffe vorgenommen haben? Vierhundert,
Und das vor dem Hintergrund, dass sowas eigentlich nie kontrolliert wird. In Hessen wird lediglich bei jede lediglich bei jeder zweihundertsten Datenabfrage die Begründung der Polizistinnen geprüft.
Ja, das heißt, deine Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ein halbes Prozent, dass du in eine Prüfung gerätst,
diese Wahrscheinlichkeit existiert auch erst seit zweitausendneunzehn, wo Hessen das eingeführt hat. In Baden-Württemberg,
gilt es für jede fünfzigste Abfrage, das heißt, deine Wahrscheinlichkeit ist bei zwei,
von einhundert. Beides immer noch sehr geringe Risiken, was mit anderen Worten bedeutet, du hast einen Freizugriff, ja? Und dieser Freizugriff wird nicht nur von ähm Möchtegern äh,
terroristischen äh Drohtätern verwendet, sondern zum Beispiel auch bekannte Fälle in äh Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, wo Polizisten versucht haben,
Sexuelle Kontakte mit Minderjährigen anzubahnen, in dem Fall eine Fünfzehnjährige, die sich an die Polizei gewandt hat, weil ihre Bilder im Internet veröffentlicht wurden und den Polizisten haben die Bilder wohl auch gefallen.
Absoluter Irrsinn, der Datenmissbrauch, der dort stattfindet.
Aber gehen Sie bitte weiter, es handelt sich ja hier nur um Einzelfälle.
Polizisten. Es kann, kann ja nicht kollektiv.
Die kann man jetzt nicht unter Generalverdacht stellen.
Nee, das sind doch immer die Guten.
Haben wir ja hier können wir auch noch kurz erwähnen, äh machen wir an anderer Stelle, aber nee, weil wir jetzt gerade hier, weil wir jetzt schon gerade hier über die Polizisten ranton, ne,
ebenfalls diese Studie über Ratio Profiling, die in Auftrag gegeben werden sollte, gegen die der Innenminister sicher gewehrt hat, weil das ja die Polizei unter einen Generalverdacht stellt.
Es kann ja nicht sein.
Ist ja verboten.
Ja, ist ja verboten.
Deswegen machen die das nicht, ne? Dann frage ich mich, was denn alles an Vorratsdaten und so weiter über mich gesammelt wird, wo ähm,
wo ich hier unter Generalverdacht geschäft bin, als wenn ich nicht wüsste, was verboten ist und was nicht, würde ich ja niemals tun.
Schön fand ich auch den Tweet von Böhmermann irgendwie. Ich glaube von gestern oder so. Und fragte er so, also warum warum wird man eigentlich immer gleich von von zur Rechtsradikalen auf Twitter so hart angegangen, wenn man mal was Kritisches zur Polizei sagt?
Ja.
Oder so. Warum eigentlich?
Die da was mit zu tun oder was?
Ähm Mario Sixtes hatte auch noch irgendwie äh.
Kennst du die eigentlich?
Leider nicht. Ich gucke ja kein Fernsehen. Jetzt auf YouTube gucke ich auch nicht.
Auch gar nicht, gibt's auch bei YouTube. Ich empfehle mal was. Weil sie hat also sie ist an sich großartig, aber sie hat dann auch noch so ein wunderbares ähm so so eine Zweitidentität. Gillette Ayshe.
Auf YouTube musst du gucken, großartig. Okay. Verlinke ich, verlinke ich, was sie sagt über Grundgesetz. Episch.
Mario Sixis äh brachte es noch hier äh gestern schön auf den Punkt. Polizei, wer nichts zu verbergen hat, hat auch nichts zu befürchten,
ebenfalls die Polizei externe Untersuchung über Polizeigewalt und Rassismus wären unerhört und stellten uns Beamte unter Generalverdacht.
Weil ich nichts hinzuzufügen. Es gibt gerade diese Petition, die wir auch verlinken, die hier diese ähm,
äh unabhängige Untersuchungen fordert und diese unabhängige Untersuchung kann ja hoffentlich bitte.
Die Behauptungen unseres Innenministers,
Unabhängig noch einmal überprüfen und belegen und insofern sollte sich doch der Innenminister in keiner Form irgendwie dagegen sperren, hier seine Zusicherung über die Integrität,
der Polizei, auch von Dritten unabhängig noch einmal bestätigen zu lassen, nicht wahr?
Auf jeden Fall.
Dann haben wir äh eine schöne Sache bei Datenzugriffen betrifft ja den Richtervorbehalt.
Der sagenumwobene. Er wurde.
Ich nenne ihn jetzt äh ab jetzt nur noch Richter vorbei, denn ähm.
Äh das Landesparlament Berlin äh lässt sich jährlich ähm von der äh Regierung äh über die Telefonüberwachung äh informieren, die die von der Polizei vorgenommen wurde, also der Landesregierung.
Da gibt's dann so ein PDF. Das hat sich der Andre angeschaut bei Netzpolitik Org. Und äh hat das mal so ein bisschen verglichen mit den Abfragen der letzten Jahre. Ähm,
Abhören von SMS nach wie vor rückläufig, weil wer heute noch SMS verwendet, ist wirklich mit einem Klammerbeutel gepudert.
Insgesamt eine halbe Million Gespräche abgehört. Das ist ungefähr jede Minute eins. Fünfundzwanzig Prozent der Ermittlungsverfahren wurden mit äh Drogen ähm.
Also mit Verdacht des Drogenhandels oder sonstigen begründet danach folgten.
Eigentum und Vermögensdelikte. Und das Spannende ist.
Kein einziger Antrag wurde von den Richterinnen abgelehnt und zwar nicht in dem letzten Jahr, sondern in den letzten zwölf Jahren.
Zwölf Jahren keinen einzigen Antrag auf äh Telekommunikationsüberwachung abgelehnt.
Richter,
gewonnen. Zack, bum, das ist die schnellste Mark, die so eine Richterin verdienen kann, irgendwie schnell stempeln, ne? Weil, wir haben das hier auch tausend Mal behandelt, den Antrag abzulehnen macht, Ärger, dem Antrag stattzugeben, ist schnell getan und der Stapel vom Papier,
ist hoch.
Die kommen auch immer Freitagnachmittag.
Natürlich. Ne, Ablehnung müsstest du begründen. Dafür müsstest du erstmal den ganzen Quatsch lesen. Ist viel Papier am Freitagnachmittag.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Am Golfkurs ist die Schlange lang.
Grad in Zeiten von Corona.
Ja. Bleiben wir bei äh Datenabfragen für die Richterinnen Vorbehalte von Nöten sind.
Und zwar ist es schon etwas länger her, dass in Deutschland die Regelungen für die Bestandsdatenauskunft äh renoviert wurden, nicht allerdings so lange, dass wir nicht damals auch schon darüber berichtet hätten. Ähm und zwar.
Wird in der Idee, welche Daten man bei so einem Internetprovider oder einem Kommunikationsanbieter abfragen kann. Grundsätzlich unterschieden in,
ähm in Bestandsdaten und wie heißt das andere Nummer?
Bestandsdaten sind die Stammdaten und Verkehrsdaten, sorry. So, Verkehrsdaten, also ähm.
Und da wird äh da gibt's natürlich Zankereien, also die grobe Unterscheidung ist, Verkehrsdaten sind das, was du darüber übermittelst,
Bestandsdaten ist das, was du dort de facto hinterlegt hast. Ja, also Anschlussinhaberin, Adresse und Sonstiges, ja?
Und in der äh ich glaube, das war eine Novelle des Gesetzes zu bestands, Datenauskunft war äh wurden dann zum Beispiel wurde also quasi die Schwellen für eine derartige ähm.
Für eine derartige Abfrage äh niedriger Gesetz, also mit anderen Worten, welcher welchen Grund für deine Abfrage gibst du als Polizistin an?
Und da war das irgendwie, ne? Früher wäre das dann gewesen, was weiß ich, muss ein Strafverfahren sein, muss ein Vorwurf von mindestens folgender Schwere sein. Und das wurde herabgesetzt auf
Ordnungswidrigkeiten und ganz allgemein für die Erfüllung der gesetzlichen Aufgaben. Mit anderen Worten, egal,
was du als äh Polizistin gerade tust, ja, weil wenn das irgendwie grob noch mit der Erfüllung deiner gesetzlichen Aufgaben gerechtfertigt werden kann, konntest du eine Bestandsdatenauskunft vornehmen. Das heißt, jede
ähm Polizistin konnte jetzt mehr oder weniger einfach mal ein Reverse-Look ab auf eine Telefonnummer machen, ja? Außerdem ähm,
war das hier äh so, dass auch äh zum Beispiel Klartextpasswörter zum Beispiel von E-Mails, äh Postfächern, Pin und Punknummern von Handys abgefragt hätten werden können,
So, dagegen haben sich zwanzig dreizehn Katharina Nokhun und Patrick Breyer,
gewendet, die Erstbeschwerdeführerinnen waren äh und sechstausenddreihundert Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben sich dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen diese Form der Bestandsdatenauskunft angeschlossen.
Und haben eben gesagt, dieses äh die Argumentation war, dieses Gesetz ist unklar, unverhältnismäßig weitreichend und widerspricht den eindeutigen Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes,
Und äh der dieser Einschätzung hat sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht nun auch angeschlossen,
das heißt mit dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde, die eben zwanzig dreizehn erhoben wurde, waren sie jetzt eben gute sechs, sieben Jahre später dann auch,
erfolgreich. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, für die Herausgabe von Passwörtern oder war der Richterin Vorbehalt vorgesehen und.
Katharina und Patrick haben damals schon argumentiert, ne, der ist in der Praxis kein relevanter Schutz und das, was wir gerade hatten, ähm,
ist. Äh ein Beleg dafür und ansonsten gibt's ja auch, ne, diese Gefahr im Vollzug und sonstige Scherze,
Also das wird neu geregelt werden müssen und es zeigt sich hier wieder einmal, das muss man jetzt Patrick Breyer spezifisch auch nochmal sagen. Das ist jemand, der sich in diese.
Ähm ja Paragraphenreiterei und diese zähen Kaugummis reinbeißt und da auch nicht loslässt und da ähm teilweise eben,
ja
Auch sehr lange dran bleibt mit wenn die Themen auch schon längst nicht mehr geeignet sind, sagen wir mal, politisches Kapital daraus zu schlagen, weil nach sieben Jahren ist, ist der Drops echt gelutscht,
Ja, da haben sich dann alle dran gewöhnt, da wird ja jetzt keiner mehr Geld für Spenden oder sonst was. Und da der bleibt eben dran,
und zieht diese Sachen durch. Ja, das äh gilt für Katharina Nokund sicherlich gleichermaßen, aber Patrick Breyer ist eben in der Politik geblieben.
Deswegen möchte ich das hier nochmal ähm.
So, die Begründung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist, die manuelle Bestandsdatenauskunft ähm.
Ähm verletzt, das Recht auf Informational, Informationelle Selbstbestimmung und das Recht auf die Wahrung des Telekommunikationsgeheimnisses der Inhaber von Telefon und Internetanschlüssen.
Das wird also neu geregelt werden müssen.
Das ist gut. Und äh ja, kann man wieder nur sagen, das sind das sind echt diese schweren Bretter, die die in der Politik zu bohren sind, ne.
Höchste Anerkennung für den Einsatz.
Ein bisschen zu Kurzmeldung würde ich sagen und zwar.
Ähm hat, erinnern sich unsere treuen Hörerinnen sicherlich, dass äh wir vor einigen Jahren.
Ähm Martin, Torsten und ich uns dieses Programm PC Wahl angeschaut haben ähm und.
Dieses Programm sehr kritisch beäugt hatten und.
Filetiert.
Ne und dann kam kurz danach oder kurz davor bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht mehr so sicher, äh ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ob das schon passiert war oder quasi schon angewandt war, aber dieses äh PC Wal wurde verkauft an die,
An das Unternehmen Vote IT.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir es nachher erst bekannt gegeben haben, äh wie auch immer. Also vote IT hatte da, wenn ich das äh richtig erinnert, hatte irgendwie sowas wie drei, dreieinhalb Millionen bezahlt, um PC Wahl zu übernehmen.
Und ähm.
Ja, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das davor war, weil ich weiß, dass ich immer noch darüber gelacht habe, dass nämlich der Typ, der PC-Wahl eigentlich geschrieben hat, sich ja äh in den Schlaf lachen muss, dass er den schwarzen Peter vorher noch verkauft hat, bevor ihm das um die Ohren geflogen ist,
Wie dem auch sei, aber,
Das Entscheidende ist, hier gibt es eine Monopolbildung, nämlich dieses Unternehmens Vote IT und dieses Unternehmen Wort-IT hat jetzt auch noch das,
Konkurrenzunternehmen IVU, Elekt übernommen. Und damit kontrolliert diese Wort-ITG GmbH jetzt.
Äh die Wahl auf Gemeinde Wahlkreis und Länderebene.
Dadurch, dass sie, dass dort PCW und der Wortmanager im äh im Einsatz sind. In Bayern ist okay Vote im Einsatz, aber ähm.
Also quasi Gemeinde, Wahlkreis Länderebene beherrschen die und auf Bundesebene sind sie jetzt ebenfalls das Monopol.
Ähm das bedeutet, die gesamte Organisation, der gesamte Meldeweg von der einzelnen Gemeinde bis zum Bundeswahlleiter ist jetzt in der Hand dieses Unternehmens.
Nicht gut. Das ist nicht gut. Ähm also nicht nur, weil die.
Wirklich keine nennenswerte Qualität liefern, sondern natürlich auch, weil du solche Übernahmen machst, um äh deine Preise anpassen zu können.
Und weil,
du, wie wir immer wieder betont haben, diese kritische Infrastruktur einfach nicht in privater Hand haben willst. Wir haben uns damals hingestellt und haben gesagt, geht doch bitte hin,
Ja, was ihr diesen Unternehmen an Lizenzkosten bezahlt für diesen ganzen Mist. Wenn ihr das in ein Projekt schaufelt, ja, wo,
Die Universitäten der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die Sicherheitsarchitektur,
beisteuern können. Wo die Mathematikerinnen äh die,
Auszählungsalgorithmen prüfen können, weil es ging ja nicht nur darum,
dass wir damals gesagt haben, hier das Ding ist unsicher und trivial äh zu zu übernehmen, sondern es geht ja auch darum, ist das, was dieses Programm am Ende ausrechnet, überhaupt korrekt?
Und da das Programm nichts anderes jemals richtig gemacht hat, stellt sich die Frage, ob das überhaupt eine komplexere Wahl,
korrekt auswerten kann. Und wir erinnern uns, wenn wir auch damals darüber berichtet, dass es da ähm Bemühungen gab, das einzusehen oder Auditberichte zu sehen, diese Software mal zu prüfen, all das findet nicht statt.
Und es wäre so, es ist so ein Risiko wieder für das Vertrauen in demokratische Wahlen, so einen Mist zu machen, ja, es geht gar nicht darum, dass am Ende der Russe die Wahl heckt
oder dass das dass da am Ende ein Fehler drin ist, sondern dass man es behaupten kann und dem nichts entgegenzusetzen ist.
Vor allem gibt's ja jetzt einen neuen Goldstandard, wie das zu laufen hat.
Äh äh da müsste es nämlich drüber aufklären.
Naja, wie es bei der Corona-Warn-App gelaufen ist, ich meine, das kann man also als Open-Source offen entwickel,
dann ist mir auch scheißegal, ob das die IT GmbH macht oder SAP. Wenn es scheiße ist, dann kriegen sie auch eine Mütze und äh der ganze Prozess ist offen, zumal man ja hier ohnehin,
mit öffentlichen Daten arbeitet. Also es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund das Ganze hier in irgend so einem geheimen Weg äh zu verschleiern. Ganz im Gegenteil, man sollte sich darüber Gedanken machen, wie man eben diese Meldung des Wahlkreises,
möglichst schnell mit,
digital unterschriebenen Information, die öffentlich gepostet werden und so weiter, dann kann das jeder zu jedem Zeitpunkt mit der kompletten Meldekette, die sowieso, ich meine, was für eine Meldekette, ich meine, es schiebst dann halt einfach ins Netz und dann steht das da halt rum und dann
kann sich das jeder selber zusammenrechnen. Du brauchst diese ganze Software.
Könntest, du könntest irgendwie sowas Schönes machen, wie Wahlauswertung, ähm,
Äh dann irgendwie hier so gleich äh Bundeswahlleiter DE Slash Bundestagswahl zwanzig dreiundzwanzig oder was auch immer.
Alle Korrekturen, die sie später noch gemacht werden, weil irgendwas falsch ausgezählt wurde, et cetera, sind dann auch transparent drin und das kannst du auch sehen, vorher, nachher, pipapo. Alles,
ein gelöstes Problem und im Prinzip brauchst du diese ganzen Unternehmen nicht. Und das Problem ist auch jetzt wo die immer ein bisschen größer werden.
Heißt das, dann haben sie halt immer mehr Mitarbeiter und dann haben sie mal mehr Einfluss und dann haben sie immer mehr
Kontakte und haben wir doch schon immer so gemacht und jetzt haben wir aber unsere Mitarbeiter aber da drauf geschult, was das ja dann alles wieder kostet, wenn wir was anderes nehmen und so, also man sieht dann immer wieder schnell
dann so dieser Status quo auch eingefroren wird und solche Unternehmen dann einfach so,
einfach weil sie schon immer da waren, äh argumentieren können, dass sie auch weiterhin da bleiben sollten, weil es ja hier auch irgendwie wichtig.
Und wenn das Open Source ist, kannst du jede Änderung daran.
Irgendwie als äh als Kleinstprojekt vergeben, kannst du sagen, hier wäre das macht, kannste äh sagen, so für jede Änderung ist ist wieder
die Konkurrenz unter den Kurderinnen und Kordern dieser Welt geöffnet und wenn die Scheißqualität liefern, wird es durch die Weltöffentlichkeit orditiert und und und. Da könnte man so schöne Dinge machen,
Man könnte so schöne Dinge machen. Aber nein, aber nein, wir machen das lieber. Wir machen das lieber anders.
Ja und vor allem, wir könnten auch weiterhin mal den Vorreiter spielen in der Abteilung, transparente Wahlen, weil ich meine, wir sehen ja nun auch grade, wie es in den USA abgeht
Ja, da also die Attacke auf das Mehlsystem ist ja nur das eine und,
aber was mich immer noch wieder schockiert ist, dass sie einfach jetzt auf diese Wahl zu gehen mit so einer Grundhaltung mit na ja,
Alle werden dann kommen, alle werden dann wählen und dann werden wir ja sehen, was die Wahrheit ist.
Ja, ihr wählt auf Wahlcomputern so, ihr thematisiert das einfach mal genau überhaupt gar nicht, obwohl vor vier Jahren euch irgendwie da schon klar war, dass da so Leute dran rumhacken.
Atmosphäre sagen, denen werden gerade die Briefkästen abmontiert, ne. Also die haben noch ein anderes Thema, um das sie sich kümmern.
Ja klar, aber es ist halt äh ein Gesamtproblem und man muss sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, wie das insgesamt äh organisiert wird, wie macht man die Wahl
macht man die Wahl transparent, wie nutzt man die Digitalen Möglichkeiten, ohne sich damit neue Probleme einzutreten
et cetera PP und äh obliegt meiner Auffassung nach Deutschland, hier so ein äh Weltmodell mal zu entwickeln und zu sagen, so hier wäre so wenn Wahl, dann aber bitte mal so.
Und dann kriegt er auch stabile Gesellschaften und nicht diesen Scheiß da.
Kommen wir zur letzten Kurzmeldung vor den Jobangeboten. Ähm,
Max Schranz war ja hier schon ähm vor zwei Sendungen zu Gast und hat mir erklärt, was da mit den Standardvertragsklauseln und dem Privacy Shield passiert ist, nämlich.
Dass beide nicht mehr als rechtliche Grundlage für.
Datentransfer in die USA herangezogen werden können und ähm jetzt haben sie folgendes gemacht, die haben auf den wichtigsten Webseiten in jedem EU-Mitgliedsstaat,
schnelle Suche durchgeführt, ob dort Google Analytics oder Facebook-Connect eingebunden wird. Und,
ähm dann haben sie bei den zuständigen Aufsichtsbehörden jeweils eine Beschwerde eingereicht. Einhundertein Stück an der Zahl.
Der Begründung, dass die Ausleitung dieser Daten für den Betrieb dieser Seite nicht nötig ist, nicht nur deswegen, ne, gibt's keine,
kein Grund das zu tun und äh sagen, ja, es gibt eben keine gültige Rechtsgrundlage mehr für diesen Datenpress, weil der weder nach oder,
also weil der sich entweder auf den Privacy oder auf die Standardvertragszahlung bezogen hat, die sind ungültig, deswegen gibt's keine Rechtsgrundlage dafür, zweitens gibt's diese US-Überwachungsgesetze,
Drittens, es ist nicht notwendig, vielen Dank, können damit aufhören, ja? Und ähm ja,
Dann haben sie noch eine Beschwerde äh über Google und Facebook äh losgeworden, weil sie diese Daten überhaupt akzeptieren unter Verletzungen der DSGVO. Weil das hätten ja auch nicht gedurft. Die hätten im Prinzip jetzt seitdem ihnen die Rechtsgrundlage weg ist, sagen müssen, alles klar. Äh
Wir müssen jetzt unsere äh API Star dicht machen. Ja, Ende vom Lied. Bin mal gespannt, also ja.
Das ist auch echt, so ein Terrier, ey. Da beißt sich da einfach in die Haxen und lässt nicht mehr los. Das könnte.
Er muss ja, was soll er denn machen.
Ja. Das weil's seine Art ist, meinst du oder was?
Verboten.
Ja.
So, dann kommen wir ähm zum letzten Punkt heute und zwar haben unsere Freunde von der digitalen Gesellschaft uns gebeten.
Darauf aufmerksam zu machen, dass dort gerade eine Stelle ausgeschrieben ist und zwar nichts anderes als die Leitung,
der Geschäftsstelle. Dafür wird eine Person in Vollzeit oder zwei Personen, in Teilzeit,
gesucht und die Aufgaben sind ja für eine funktionierende Vereinsverwaltung sorgen, ja, inklusive äh Mitgliederspenden, Finanzverwaltung.
Koordination mit Steuer und Lohnbüro, aber vor allem natürlich das Planen, Koordinieren der Veranstaltung, wie zum Beispiel den Netzpolitischen Abend, Fundraising,
und die Weiterentwicklung der Organisation. Ich denke, insbesondere, was die Weiterentwicklung der Organisation angeht,
äh hat die Stelle hier ähm viele Freiheitsgrade, ja? Ähm die digitale Gesellschaft stand auch schon mal besser da,
und ähm entsprechend kann man hier mit Gestaltungswillen auch viel machen, weil man ja eine mächtige.
Marke und ein gutes Team hat, was äh glaube ich auf was wieder ausgebaut werden kann und sollte, also hier gibt's eine Stelle, denke ich, mit,
Gestaltungspotential, natürlich auch dem Formulieren von Positionen, Stellungnahmen, Presseinformationen.
Ähm und die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Ja, ich denke, das ist hier eine Stelle mit sehr viel,
Freiheitsgraden, die einer Person, die diese Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten nutzen möchte,
Äh für eine Person, die diese Gestaltungsmöglichkeit nutzen möchte, sicherlich interessant ist. Äh Bewerbung bitte bis zum vierundzwanzigsten achten, das ist in wenigen Tagen.
Ähm aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass hier unter Umständen auch,
eine gnädige Nachfrist gewährt werden könnte. Ähm PGP-Schlüssel äh wird angegeben, wir haben die Stellenausschreibung bei uns,
in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Ja, das bringt uns zu einem anderen schon lange nicht mehr gehört, ein Segment, nämlich den Termin.
Und zwar hat sich ja der Chaos, Computerclub, beziehungsweise Teile der Veranstaltungsorga, dazu entschieden,
die nun grade reihenweise als Präsenzveranstaltung ausfallenden Termine wie den Easter Hack,
durch online Veranstaltungen zu kompensieren, dass digital verteilte Online-Chaos, also das Divok.
Ähm es gab, dass äh Diwok Home Lounge im Mai, es gab der Stevokin Service im April und es wird jetzt vom vierten bis sechsten September das Divokus geben.
Ähm.
Wie gesagt, ein Online-Event, das sich anstrengend auch als Communityversammlung dienen zu können. Die Website ist dieselbe wie bisher, die Punkt C3 Rock Punkt DE und ähm könnt euch da ja schon mal.
Ein bisschen eingrooven.
Das bedeutet wir kommen zum Ende der Sendung.
Wir kommen zum Ende der Sendung und das bedeutet, ich danke. Soll ich machen?
Ich danke Jonas, Abdelkader, Volkmar, Christian und Svenne, nämlich auch hier in den in der Durststrecke ohne Sendung äh nicht vergessen haben und äh,
Grüße freundlich zurück.
Genau. Und wir bedanken uns natürlich auch bei allen anderen, die uns nicht äh vergessen haben durch regelmäßige Spenden, unterstützen und äh,
Kommentare liefern und auch von so einer Sommerpause nicht äh allzu frustriert sind.
Jetzt geht's wieder weiter und jetzt wird äh auch wieder geliefert. Wie ist so unsere Art ist.
Ja. Tragt schön eure Masken. Es ist ungefähr die geringste Einschränkung, die euch für die nächsten Monate bevorsteht. Wenn ich das mal so freundlich sagen darf.
Genau auch nochmal ein Prozent Akku für die Corona-Warn-App. Spendieren kann auch nicht schaden und so und dann schauen wir mal, ob äh die goldenen Zwanziger nicht vielleicht doch noch ihren Ruf.
Uff mit deinen goldenen zwanzig.
Wieso? Da war doch auch Depression und so weiter und danach wurde nur noch gefeiert.
Wann? Wann war das? Wann kommt das? Zwanzig dreiundzwanzig oder wann?
Es kommt in dem Moment, wo du nicht mehr damit rechnest.
Der war schon längst.
Gut. Okay. Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Okay. Haltet die Ohren steif und die Masken über der Nase, bis denn.